You must think I'm like literally crazy. No, I think you're very
ego-driven and somewhat kind of a huge piece of [__]
inner personally. I think it's insane to me that you could sit
in a chat and
>> You're a terrorist. I'm a terrorist. Because I debate.
>> Probably bring me you bring Is that what I just said?
>> On what other ground am I a [__] terrorist?
How am I a terrorist? Terrorist should be [__] >> about
it. How am I a terrorist? When I say that, what do you think
I mean? Do you think that I mean because You have no clue whatsoever.
What If you have no clue whatsoever, what do you mean I'm a terrorist?
Speak plainly. You know you don't believe that. First of all,
shut the [__] up, okay? Um number one. Number two,
like if we do, it's just because this guy has an such an unfathomable
level of [__] against me, including doxing me, including
every single tiny reference to me has any epsilony, pedosiny,
or whatever. And he's like reading down my TV from the other
room on stream.
Yo. [music]
Woah. Hey, what's up, buddy? Not much, dude. Just another day
in America.
Another day in America. Of um Firstly, I'm just curious, what
type of communist do you think that Aaron is? I'm not sure. Not
that it doesn't matter for Mel versus communists. Is there a
particular type?
Well, do you know what the most common type of communist is?
What if 99% were Marxist-Leninists?
What if I don't know. What's What's your
Well, if somebody said I'm a communist and 99% were MLs, and
they didn't clarify another type of communism, wouldn't you assume
that they're just an Not if they deny it.
Has she denied She said, "I'm not a Marxist-Leninist"? Yes.
So, if somebody denies having a particular ideology, is that
enough? If Nick Fuentes says I'm not a neo-Nazi, does that mean
Absent other evidence absent other evidence, Destiny just said,
"If she says she's a communist and you have no other information,
can you assume she's an ML?" He says, "Not if she denies it."
They're not a neo-Nazi. Unless I have a basis to ascertain Unless
I have a basis to mistrust them. >> ascertaining what their
I don't have faith, man. >> Unless I have a basis to mistrust
them if they show um perspectives that are incompatible or sort
of credibly indicative of the ideology, perhaps I would doubt
them. But if there's no reason to doubt, I just trust. Okay.
Do you think that Aaron believes that the capital class will
ever willingly give up their power or capital? I kind of believe
that. There could be democratic ways to achieve it.
I think it's a little bit um Why are we talking Why are we talking
about Economoy? Hold on, let me repeat that question. I don't
think you heard me. I answered it. Does Aaron believe that capital
will willingly part with their power, with their wealth, with
their capital? I'm not sure.
Then how can you know if she's an ML or Because I told you, just
because I don't know the specific answer to that question, I
assume people are telling me the truth unless I have a reason
to believe otherwise, and unless there's an overriding reason
to doubt their identification. That's unreasonable, yes or no?
Do people generally Are people generally Why doesn't Pisco just
say, "Hey, didn't she go and like canvas with you?"
Didn't she go and like totally try to use the democratic system
to achieve a movement in a direction she appreciates,
>> forthcoming with radical or extreme ideologies, or are
they generally a little a bit more kind of like concealing of
them? I think Aaron is incredibly forthcoming. In fact, that's
why she says she labels herself a communist as opposed to a
When she called herself a communist as opposed to a socialist,
what what was the What What did she say alongside that? Didn't
she mention that? She >> shy about being socialist, but
they're Yeah, why would they be shy about that? Presumably because
they think that the connotation of the term communism has baggage
it more or less represents a reason, um despite, you know, very
small differences in ideology. And that's more evidence, I think,
that she's not a Marxist-Leninist because she wouldn't
socialist ideologies, which no sense Marxist-Leninist, under
her term.
Is Is Destiny really on here to discuss Straight Ray's ideology?
He's not even going to discuss the issue, which is, "Hey, make
a recommendation. What's the odds you
It's not even that. It is, "Um What kind of communist do you
think Aaron is?"
>> So, when people look at your community and they see
that it might be infested, like half of it with a certain type
of chatter, why is your response, "Should I ban X?"
Because I think the
Because the observation is based on people's emotional feelings,
how they feel about the first certain thing being talked about.
And so Piscatella says, "Can you give me like a categorical reason?
Can you give me a rule for this that I can apply universally?
Otherwise, I don't want to do it." >> At the uh
infested as you put it is um
sort of suggesting a normative say like implication that I'm
doing something
So, I'm asking for
If you came into a liberal streamer's
Sure. If you came into a liberal Is this just going to be the
exact thing that I said it was going to be? Is it going to be
Destiny coming in and trying to give examples to to totally emotionally
signal and provide no actual prescription? Just emotionally signal
and try to make Piscatella look bad >> Well, streamer's
chat 50% of that chat was hardcore MAGA. >> No way.
What would your assumption be about the
I think if um there's a community a lib community
with a bunch of MAGA people in the
I think it um probably either suggests
liberal streamer interacts a lot with
um or potentially that there's something that the uh MAGA audience
finds useful about the content or they like the content perhaps.
Uh reiterating my first statement on this very important topic.
Last time it was discourse.
Uh-oh. Is this going to be the Is this the Lubu Bu response?
I feel like I haven't clicked on it yet, but it might just be
the Lubu Bu response.
Oh, no, it's not.
Being included in a conversation about the influence of Vladimir
Lenin, Joseph Stalin, Mao Zedong, Donald Trump, and Hasan [__]
in American politics.
Wow. It's a different response. All right. So, then if somebody
sees
>> all the liberal learn guys, your chat seems uniquely
draw people that are hardcore [__] on other members
of the show. Why do you think that is? I think people
hard on other members of the show come to my channel because
um they agree more with me, disagree with them. And the people
who agree more with them are on me on their channels.
So, Do you agree with that? Do you agree with that? >> Yeah,
they [__] on me a lot. Uh no, I don't. I will get
I will to that, yeah. Do you think that the people in Hutch's
channel, do you think that they [__] on you in the
same way that your audience shits on Hutch? From what I've seen,
um, it looks very
I'll I'll I'll describe it if you don't mind, then you can tell
me if I'm wrong. Um, descriptions of bad faith, saying he doesn't
know what he's talking about, saying that he's grifting, um,
saying that he's stupid, saying that he, um, has some sort of
negative design.
Is that because of your political disagreements with Hutch or
is that after you go in and you and Hutch have like a huge argument?
I think that that is when he and I are
I just get an emotionally signal. Aren't you like kind of an
[__] to Hutch? Aren't you like kind of an [__]
to your other co-host? Aren't you like kind of an [__]
to the IRI? Aren't you like kind of those guys over? Aren't you
like totally these guys over right now?
>> Is it when you guys are just disagreeing or is it when
you're going in super No, I think it's, um, at least I'm not
sure. The Are you suggesting that Hutch's chat is only mean to
me if and when we disagree? That's not true. It's an implication.
That is my I'm Not mean. You keep backing off. I know you're
trying to play the game, right? I'm not saying simply disagreeing
or we're being mean, like talking about being like like pretty
vitriolic. Uh, like very toxic. Um, Hutch's chat will do it.
You You tried to do this trick earlier where you showed the stream
of debate and you looked at the comments and you're like, "These
comments are mean to me." I'm like, "Well, of course you're being
a massive [__] towards Hutch." I wasn't being an
[__] Why are the comments in your chat always so
unbelievably vitriolic towards Well, let's just deal with the
disclaimer. Okay. It's so obvious what's going to happen, man.
It's like it should actually be embarrassing for Destiny to get
soul read this hard. Like he's not going to have any categorical
He's not going to have a prescription. No rule. I'm saying it's
very embarrassing for Destiny to be soul read this hard that
he has no rule, he has no prescription. The only thing he has
is emotionally signaling that Pisco's a to his friends. This
is the exact same thing that he constantly told his own friends
to get [__] on repeatedly over and over again for
years.
Why are the comments in your chat always so unbelievably vitriolic
Well, let's just deal with the disclaimer. Okay. It's maybe not
Hutch. I don't know. No, I think that Hutch reached out to me
to have a conversation. I let him drive the conversation. I gave
him honest Either >> two things prevent you from being
an [__] I don't know how he was an [__]
You got this. When somebody says so we can go back one super
easiest comparison in the world. When somebody says would you
rather vote for Newsom or J.D. Vance? If you're a reasonable
person who's a liberal, it should be an easy question to answer,
right? That's Okay. If somebody says If somebody says Hassan
versus J.D. Vance, if Hakeem's issue is with the illiberalism,
why would you pretend that that question is of the same quality
of question as Newsom versus J.D. Vance? So, it That wasn't the
question. It's It's not. Nobody said that. You're making that
up. You're introducing that as if that's a thing that was being
discussed. It's not. Hakeem answered the question. that I was
calling him out for not answering. And Pisco gave him enough
reason or enough time to clarify his answer on the question.
Um Well,
because it was an example of a person who was whose moral character
is insanely horrible to show how immune he is to the principle
of harm reduction unlike these tankies who won't stomach a candidate
that isn't like perfect. I will stomach highly, highly imperfect
candidates including someone like Epstein, including segregationists
for the purpose of harm reduction. Do you think Hakeem would
have the same answer if Epstein was a Nazi? No. Do you think
he'd have the same answer if Epstein was a communist? No. Okay,
so then you understand that point. So, then why would you have
such a freak out response when you can't quickly and easily answer
Epstein versus Hassan when Hassan is a self-admitted whatever
I don't know how you have him categorized communist, Marxist,
Leninist, whatever. Why would you imagine you'd have a quick
response when you understand that the point of the Epstein comment
was that Epstein is probably broadly liberal. He has a deplorable
moral character, but you would go with the deplorable moral character
who's a liberal over the guy who's illiberal. And then act like
it's a huge own and then scream at him for 30 minutes when you
put two illiberals
that Hold on. Because it's Because if if Vance and Hassan are
equal, but you would vote for Epstein over Vance, then you would
vote for Epstein over Hassan.
Right? That's the thing It's literally
oppositional logic. Okay. And then he's trying to get more information
about why we're asking politics or because he's looking for an
own in that circle. That's not That's not what's going on there.
I'm obviously trying to own him for 30 minutes. But, the reason
is because he didn't ask for Epstein's policies when he was talking
about that. And so, it wasn't appropriate. But, do you see how
you knew exactly what he was saying because you're not autistic?
You know exactly what the plan is bringing up Epstein. It would
show somebody of a severe moral decay who would still ostensibly
defend the liberal world order. Yeah. The other assumption for
for Vance in the hypothetical that he pushed By the way, he pushes
But, the the whole thing is he's saying that Vance and Hassan,
when it's just Vance and Hassan, he's trying to to get a dunk
on Hassan that he doesn't actually believe in. Because if he
actually believed that when he says that they're equal, I wouldn't
make a decision myself. When he says that then
obviously
he's lying about Hassan or he's lying about Epstein. I don't
know which one. So the whole conversation is just trying to get
him to resolve the contradiction he's introduced.
Am I right for this exchange? I hope you don't think that was
bad faith or whatever. Um but yeah, he didn't have the same kind
of introspection on Epstein's political ideology when he did
the Vance comparison and he did for Hassan. And so that I think
it informs something I mean something must inform that. Why is
it so easy >> you think What do you think informs
I'm not sure because he still doesn't give an answer.
He's he's he's currently He's probably just Well because it because
Well because it probably feels a little bit like a like a clip
farm. Answer's not very relevant here. I would imagine if you
pose the question to uh Hutch and say, "Let's assume that Epstein
is a strong liberal who also likes to hurt kids." The the answer,
by the way, the answer is literally just that he was overblowing
Hassan's illiberalness when he said he wouldn't vote for Hassan
over J.D. Vance. He was doing the same thing Hassan was doing
where he was trying to signal that Hassan is bad and so he said
that but probably
you know, in the booth voting voting pen to your head, you vote
for Hassan. You stomach it, you vote for Hassan, the guy who's
actually shown some concern about liberal democracy.
As much as you may believe his overall ideology pushes in the
other direction. >> Hassan [__] who is a strong
illiberal and will do everything he can to destroy the current
liberal system? And he would say, "Well, I would probably go
with Epstein same way I went with Epstein over J.D. Vance." Right?
Do you think he would you imagine he'd answer that way? I think
that I'm not sure because he hasn't said what his answer He said
at the end and so if I'm going to thank you No because we can't
go from any other part of the conversation. It's impossible for
you to make an to guess what the answer would Because I believe
Hutch because I'm good faith and because I trust Hutch. No, you're
using bad faith. You're using bad faith. You're trying to find
out. You're Well no, I don't want you to explain because you're
going to say, "Well, because he said these words." Hutch is too
dumb. Hutch is too dumb to come to this conclusion on his own.
Pisco, you have to explain to him why he's dumb to prove that
he's not dumb or something. I don't even know. Like let Hutch
Pisco is trying not to tell Hutch what his opinion is. He's letting
him work it out. >> I tried to tease it out in debate in
in an ultra high stakes environment you're jumping down my throat
good faith
But like his inability
illustrate why he chose
all of understanding disappears What do
assumes the character people more
The reason I give the answer I don't know is because that's the
answer Hutch follow I don't where your position I'm not sure.
And so for describe position reasoning I think bad I'd be I think
you're doing I don't when he I don't know. I trust He's a No,
I trust this you like spun all crazy irrelevant of like well
what you just totally Hutch Well what came they couldn't their
entire what if I'm just come in Dude it's so tragic. If you're
about similar long ago about
basically remark we're going we're assuming everything political
system stays the same. I'd rather have in office nobody likes
it so it do anything. It's meaningless question right? Usually
assumption going decent amount done. So I think I don't what
conversation probably more of confusion what capability would
a even rather than him always getting why he posed hypothetical
first or rather suggested he would for over That's not interpretation
why he answered I don't I mean we clarified I wasn't talking
about commenting I've Hutch commenting a little his own Well
so if you to guess why do you think he thinks oh boy more confused
I guess versus I haven't anything else so honestly illiberal
would say absolutely
would defend order you don't what would answer why do you think
you don't Do you doesn't or do you think just tell you I think
doesn't I think doesn't because I trust him and that's what he
told me. He doesn't Okay. So you think is clueless there he has
no concept of No, it's called being or being conflicted.
But he It's literally doing the thing that like probably has
an intuition about Hutch thinks. He's saying that Hutch said
he didn't know. So I'm going to apply what I think is Hutch's
opinion to him because that would rude. He said he didn't know,
trying not to attach anything to him that he hasn't ex- explicitly
said he believes. >> Wasn't conflicted. Do you think he
rolls back on his answer of Epstein versus J.D. Vance then? No.
I think you're seeing the I think you're seeing the problem.
But you don't know Well, no, I the answer's quite obvious. I
think it's exactly what I said before. Yeah, so this is I think
this is Hutch's opinion,
Hutch
wouldn't take this back for a long time in this conversation.
You just said it was an obvious Yeah. So what So when I say So
when I say it should be an easy layup, that's correct, right?
Obvious.
Well, I if you're willing to Yeah, bite insane bullets while
you're having a conversation with a friend where 50% of the chat
is invested in personally character assassinating you, I don't
know. In his position, it might be a lot tougher. So maybe you
can understand my consternation in the actual live and learn
episode. Something that I feel should be a layup, where it's
like, "Wait, you've already laid it out. He's a liberal. You've
already given it for J.D. Vance. The obvious answer here is to
say you prefer Epstein." Maybe you can understand why someone
given those priors would be like a little bit annoyed that it's
not being answered. Especially because I don't think I don't
think that Hutch is bad faith enough to sort of hide his answer
if he really felt it was harm reduction. That's his whole point.
And so it seems like you're assuming more bad faith than I am.
I think I think the main confusion is why why the question of
Epstein versus
Beca- The reason why I asked the question It's a great question.
The reason I asked the question Epstein versus Hassan is Dude,
I'm sorry. This whole thing was a horrible idea for Pisco. This
is just I think I think it's going to be I I hope after this
time he just learns like that like trying to talk to these people
is wrong. They are operating from a base level of what Destiny
says is correct. What Destiny like advocates for is correct.
Like all these chatters who are pushing him in this direction,
all of his own community members who push him in this direction,
that's how they're operating. They just want to see Destiny win.
There's no rules here. There's no prescriptions. You can't win
by being logical. And now Hutch is going to get at it. It's all
going to be emotional signaling. You're just really making me
feel bad. Pisco, you're making me feel really bad. I was like
under pressure and you're trying to clip farm me. >> Hutch
said he was indifferent. >> There's no win There's no win.
There is no win here. There's no win. Essentially indifferent.
as between Hassan and J.D. Vance. And I think I'd already known
that Hutch had double triple quadruple down on Epstein over Vance
until Wait, wait, wait, let's real quick. Why was he indifferent
on Hassan versus Vance? Cuz he thinks that the harm between them
presumably is negligible as relates liberal institutions and
societal damage. Okay, so that's your answer. Then why would
I clip farm? I'm not clip It's diff- Okay, let's say that Hutch
would have finally bit the bullet. Let's say Hutch would have
said, "Okay, fine." And assuming Epstein would defend the world
order, the liberal world order, despite the fact that Epstein,
you know, has abused children, I would vote for him over Hassan.
What if your next question was, "Okay, let's assume that Epstein
raped a thousand children. Would you still vote for him over
Hassan? Do you think that him struggling to answer that would
be him being bad faith or confused?" What do you think the feeling
would be, "Why are you asking me this I I think that would I
think that question is answered. I mean, I know you're not talking
about great hypotheticals because that is part of how you have
always run your intellectual debates, your philosophical debates.
>> with great hypotheticals. What I have a problem with
is that you brought up the Hassan versus Epstein thing when you
already know the answer to No, I don't think I brought it up
to clip farm. No, no, no. Clip farming implies that I'm I'm wanting
him to be attacked online, that I have a malicious motive. >> what
it feels I'm telling you that that's what every single person
in the universe If you didn't intend that, that's fine, but it's
a failure of communication because I don't know how else you
could ever interpret that question. You know why he's asking
it? It's It's just a It's totally
Right? Like Hutch is trying to go after Hassan. Hutch is saying,
"I don't have any personal grievance against Hassan." But Pisco
basically exposed that Hutch was over playing how bad Hassan
was in the hypothetical to win an argument. Now, why is there
no conversation about why Hutch would lie there to win an argument
with Pisco to not have to bite a bullet in previous conversation?
If a liberal versus liberal, you know how he's interpreting Hassan
versus Vance. He thinks to himself, and he's like, "What about
Epstein? Would you rather have a child raped or would you have
Hassan Derangement Syndrome?" That's how that question's going
to come across to every person. So, the reason the reason the
reason why I asked it, and it's not bad faith, unlike like what
if he had just, you know, But it it literally exposed By the
way, it literally exposed that Hutch was over playing the opposition
to Hassan.
Hutch was over playing it. I got running or walking away from
the inside. But Hutch is going to come on here and and it's all
going to be that Pisco's the super mean bully with no cat no
categorical recommendation, no prescription, nothing. Just because
that happens. Or actually just after that happened, does your
choice change or something like that? And the reason it's different
is because he'd already bit the bullet on the Epstein thing.
So I felt that that was like a reasonable extrapolation of his
comfort level vis-a-vis the clips. He'd already been clipped
relentlessly on this Epstein thing and he seemed he was comfortable
with it. Isn't that a reasonable thing? >> by who? Clipped
by who? By Hassan. And then your question is would you vote for
Epstein over Hassan, the guy who has doxxed you and who's been
clipping and bullying the [__] out of you? And also
by the way, I think you're going to Did you hear what I just
said? Yeah, I heard everything you just said.
Uh so bold from this re-tard soy boy. You just said I'm personally
motivated. But I just want to make sure you know that you know
these are claims that you said to I don't think I could do that.
I don't think I could do that.
on for this take for the the last day or two that you decide
to then up the ante for the same people that are [__]
on him and then say would you vote for Epstein over Hassan? >> That's
precisely what I thought I wasn't doing. I mean so I just gave
you an explanation about So I just gave you an explanation for
why I didn't feel it was up in the ante. The reason is he'd already
shown his comfort with the Epstein comparison to Vance.
You don't think it's upping the ante then to make a comparison
to the same guy that's been harassing you online next? What for
what purpose? You're not trying to tease out any more principles.
You already know where he stands on it. What more are you trying
to tease out? We're trying to confirm finally that Hassan views
>> what? Hassan sorry, that Hutch views Hassan and JD Vance
as equivalent. And this is the way to do that. No, no, they're
not equivalent. They're in the same bucket. They're both illiberal.
That he's indifferent as between them for a choice. Because they're
both illiberal. He might not necessarily be indifferent but it's
Why not just ask him that? Why make the comparison to the harassing
guy? No, no, Soy Boy will try. You're trying to make the comparison
to a guy that's been harassing him along with his entire community
and half the internet over the past day. Why would you do that
beyond the ill informing? So that's not my intent. Soy Boy will
try to asking him as between Hassan and Epstein sorry, Hassan
and JD Vance and the response was Destiny said let him find out
for himself when just when Hutch got doxxed, right? Actually,
that was when
That was with Josiah at some point. He said that about Josiah.
Yes, he said let let Josiah Hold on, I literally just pulled
that for you. So I I actually have it uh saved. One
Uh oh, it's not that one. Hold on. This
Picture work? Oh, it was with Hutch, too.
Send it to them so they can see what they're doing. This is about
the the doxing of Hutch and um this is like a repost of the doxx
of the PP people on Kiwi Farms. And Destiny says, "Send it to
who?" Oh, Destiny, Josiah and Hutch and stuff. Oh, man, they
can figure out themselves. They can figure it out themselves.
It was Hutch, too, yeah.
Crazy. That's really crazy that like he didn't give a And now
he's like using it explicitly to emotionally signal against Pisco.
Very cool, very cool. >> give an answer. He said I would
shoot He wanted an answer for for 30 minutes. You don't know.
Why do you exaggerate like that? Do you think anyone believes
it? I'm not. It was so awkward that a guest was six words in
answering a question. He started screaming saying, "You disagree
with Hutch then, right?" I'm not exaggerating at all. It was
incredibly uncomfortable. That's why he got upset. little words
you No, that's that's a different issue. That's the issue here.
The next that conversation you had with the next day was some
of the most insane like running around in circles of well, if
they were elected, they wouldn't be able to achieve their goals
and who would blah blah blah. Like but you you earlier in this
conversation, you already know why he would choose Epstein over
Vance. You know why the confusion would be there. >> know.
I I I don't know that because he says I don't know. Wait, okay,
hold on. Just to say something quick. You don't know why he would
choose Epstein over Vance now. Oh, I'm sorry. Sorry. I I misheard
you. I thought you meant Hassan over >> Okay. You know
why he said Hassan versus Vance would be a difficult argument,
right? Um I know that he No, I don't because he said he's indifferent,
essentially. So, I don't know that.
Do you think that the reason why he might be indifferent is because
of the quality that led him to choose Epstein over Vance is a
quality that he feels like Vance and Hassan share, namely being
illiberal? Right, which should make the Epstein
question trivial. It is. So, unless you have a reason why he's
Why do you Because he's Because he just got clipped that he's
been harassed for the past what, 24, 48 >> Yeah, but I
don't think Hutch is lying to me when he says he doesn't know.
I think he's honest that he doesn't >> I think he was I
think he spent the next however much time trying to Okay, so
you Pisco just won, right? Hutch didn't say it was a layup. Hutch
said, "I still can't tell which way I go." Hutch didn't say it
was a layup, right? Cuz I don't think it's a layup. In fact,
Hutch believes the opposite. Hutch believes that he probably
take Hasan. He said, "That's why I need to know Epstein's politics
cuz I'm probably leaning Hasan." Do you think he just doesn't
know? He's a He has no idea. >> No, I It's a layup based
on the logic, but Hutch doesn't believe the logic, and that's
Pisco's intuition. That's what he's trying to get on. Did he
say that? I think he's conflicted. He doesn't know. He said that
before I get to get to. You're the one saying that's not the
case. He can't possibly cuz I know it's not the case cuz it's
a stupid answer. You either have no idea what he said to you,
which I don't know why you talked to him about this for hours
cuz it's painfully obvious to everyone else listening what he's
trying to say. But you're telling me right now you know No, when
you believe he doesn't know if he would choose a liberal defender
Epstein over an illiberal Hasan [__] You have no
idea. You have no idea what he would choose. You kind of fell
into a little [__] right here because you understand
what Hutch said. I don't know if you're listening to the conversation
that you reviewed. I did. It's not about what >> Hutch Wait,
no, listen. Listen. Listen,
Wait, just chill. Just chill. No, it doesn't matter. Just chill.
So, the reason why you just stepped in it is because Hutch told
me that the reason he was hesitating was the opposite. That the
reason he was hesitating is because and why he thought I was
being like that >> see him being referred to in the chat.
I'm very excited. That has That Hutch >> My ears are burning
already. I'm being referred to. Oh my god. >> opposite
of what you just suggested. Hutch said in this conversation I
do not believe that No. Well, do you want me to pull it up? I
have the time. We'll We'll pull this up right now. >> want,
pull it up. We can watch it. Sure.
>> Let's go. Let's go. Let's go.
Just curious cuz I'm just curious. Is this a link from Just Curious?
No. Okay. I don't talk to I can't talk to Pisco. Pisco don't
want to talk to me,
Uh
plotting. We're plotting. We're always plotting. We're always
plotting. We're always moving. >> I'm going to share my
screen with you so you can see it.
It doesn't matter. Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait. It informs my
state of mind,
Clearly it must inform But wouldn't me asking for qualifiers
imply that I think that I intuitively think that Hasan would
be slightly better? If I don't need qualifiers for Vance and
Trump, I would say, "Oh, no, I would never vote for them." But
I So, you're wrong.
I don't I You haven't played any of the clip. I don't know what
he's referring to at this point. Is he saying that Hasan would
be slightly better than >> Yeah, and you said that 20 Yeah,
and your your suggestion was that he would think that they're
equivalent and therefore it's obvious that that's the answer
he would give. And here he is saying it's intuitive that Hassan
is slightly better. >> they were equivalent. What did I
say? No, they're indifferent between them. No, I said that Yeah,
yes, they would he would be indifferent between Vance and Hassan,
but they would both be in the bucket of illiberal. So, one might
be slightly better than the other, but not that it would make
it like so obviously preferable that he would choose Hassan over
a liberal defending Epstein. That's what we were talking about
before you were looking for this clip. He gave you this clip.
No, no one gave me this clip. I remember this conversation.
>> Hutch saying the exact opposite of me, which was that
oh, he would obviously choose Hassan over Epstein. That's not
this. You're saying here he would choose Hassan over JD Vance,
which may may be true, but the reality is the reason why I said
he would kill himself is both of these people are in the bucket
of super illiberal people, which at that point you're voting
for a Hitler or Hitler minus 3 million.
Wait a second. So, your contention before was it's so obvious
Hutch prefers Epstein he just can't say it because you're clip
farming. How do you make sense of this clip where he's where
he's saying that >> sense of it? Because because Hassan
has doxxed him and he's got tons of people harassing him and
the whole Snark Left, half of which are in your chat, are so
set against him on this. And now you're asking for a really unnecessary
comparison that you and Hutch both already know the answer to.
For what purpose other than for getting him increasingly clipped
by the guy who's already doxxed and harassed him for the next
like week. Why would you ever do What's the purpose? I don't
know if you just heard what I said, and you think I'm going to
like forget and get distracted, but what I just said was like
your contention is I'm bad faith because it's obvious that he
prefers Epstein over Hassan he just can't say it. In the clip
we just saw, um he said the reason I hesitated intuitively is
because I think Hassan is slightly better than Vance.
It's different than what you're
Di- What are you Are you guys Did you guys get the clip?
Like he spent this Like I listened to this whole 3-hour talk.
The 3-hour talk is him constantly saying the problem with Vance
and Hassan is they are both illiberal. Now, you try to dress
this up by saying well, maybe they can't get what they want,
whose policies are in a closer direction to yours or whatever
else. And so, that adds a little bit more to this conversation,
but given the opportunity for a fully lived
your neighbor >> Epstein Watch your neighbor, okay?
We're in everybody's head. Pretty sure >> All the time.
You can ask him after the show. Pretty sure Hutch would say,
"I guess I would go with Epstein." All these people are I would
go with Epstein over JD Vance because JD Vance and his son both
want to destroy the liberal world order. That's why Hutch in
this in this conversation literally asked you, "Don't you think
that that Hassan would um what was it? Try to try to Oh, he said
on day one would he give intelligence to China or some other
thing?" And then you asked like "Has he ever said that before?"
Something stupid. Like he asked this hypothetical like these
are things that
I I don't remember. Whatever it was was stupid. You can go find
that timestamp in the video if you want. But like the obvious
the point of the The point of the question is that Hassan would
do things that would fundamentally destroy the United States
the same way that JD Vance would fundamentally destroy the United
States. And he thinks Epstein probably wouldn't destroy the United
Okay. I mean I I I I guess I don't know your position. It's your
position still that not withstanding Hutch right there saying
intuitively he thinks Hassan is better. Notwithstanding that
that it's still
>> Better than Vance. Better than Vance and that's why
he's pausing. Oh, whoops. Right? And that's why he's pausing.
>> you like No, cuz he's asking why maybe hypothetically
why would he need more qualifiers maybe for Epstein or whatever
here. But like this is in the middle of a conversation where
he's like Dude.
>> So like So I can't So you're calling me bad faith because
I don't assume that Hutch's answer is it's so obvious Epstein.
He treats them the same way. When here he's almost signaling
that the intuition, I'm sorry, directly signaling the intuition
is the opposite. The reason he's hesitating is and asking for
additional qualifiers
about Epstein with respect to Hassan is because intuitively he
thinks Hassan is
And if he thinks Hassan is better
um it's likely he would say Hassan over Epstein. Sorry, and and
also Sorry, Hassan over Vance.
And therefore not being different. >> anything to do with
the Epstein comparison. He's just giving reasons why he might
have The actual answer >> No, it does. Listen to it. Listen
to it. It informs my state of mind, right? Here it is. Clearly
it must inform my state of mind, right? But wouldn't me asking
for qualifiers imply that I think that I intuitively think that
Hassan would be slightly better. If I don't need quality and
and that is better than Vance. He's asking for qualifiers. The
qualifiers he's referencing are with Epstein. Qualifiers for
Vance and Trump I would say, "Oh no, I would never vote for them."
But I need qualifiers for Hassan. Doesn't that mean that I'm
thinking more about possibly supporting Hassan?
I mean, I don't know, man. It's the direct opposite of what you're
Don't you think that some of the qualifiers might be like the
fact that we have a Trump administration right now and we have
a J.D. Vance that could theoretically assume Trump's position
and we've already seen that Trump is a massive threat and is
doing everything he can to destroy the liberal democratic world
order. That some of those additional qualifiers might be how
much power would Hassan have if he were in office, the things
that you guys literally directly talked about in this conversation,
that those would be things that might relevantly inform his opinion
and that he might want to be He doesn't It doesn't really matter
how he answers the Epstein versus J.D. Vance question because
J.D. Vance is not coming after Hodr on Twitter that I've seen
and as far as I know Epstein is seems most people believe is
he's dead. So, probably doesn't matter how he answers that. But
if you're going to start getting into the weeds of like Hassan
versus Epstein, okay, well, maybe we need to add some more qualifiers
on here so it doesn't seem like especially when you've got Epstein
the multi child versus Hassan the guy who presents himself publicly
is the guy who just wants single payer health care, right? Maybe
it's worth flushing that analogy out a little bit more especially
given the last 24 to 48 hours on Twitter, you know, running roughshod
over with all the tweets and the quote tweets.
Well, I don't know what to tell you. I which is it? I just officially
ended the hypothetical so that's why I just dragged him in. Maybe
he can answer this question. >> wait, wait, wait, wait,
wait, so Hodr can answer Wait, wait, wait, wait, Hodr can answer
Wait, wait, wait, just real quick. If you don't know, if you
don't know the answer to that question, I'm assuming that you
and friends you and Hodr at least He's not needed. Sure, sure,
sure. It's getting a little loud, okay, okay. >> had this
conversation with him for four or five hours and you have no
clue what the answer is to the question that inspired this extra
three and a half hour conversation.
What's going on there? How is there such a failure or breakdown
of communication?
I think that he's conflicted. I mean Hutch you can tell us more
about at the end of our conversation you said you're not sure.
I accept that answer and I don't know. No, no, I So listen, like
when when we spoke, I said that the the fact that I hesitated
when you asked the I swear to God if we say Epstein one more
time but when you ask me like Epstein versus Hassan, I said that
I would rather Minecraft myself and and and the questions you
had asked me before it was like
it was like Hassan versus Trump and I think I said the same thing.
But the fact that I hesitated in that moment and I I wanted qualifiers.
Like I just don't think that that's a big deal. Like maybe I
was in a different mood that day or maybe it indicates
Pisco could be a total dick here but he is friends with Hutch
so I don't know if he has the strength. But basically when when
Hutch is asking for qualifiers, isn't that isn't it just a layup?
Isn't it just obvious what the answer is? Isn't it isn't it super
obvious?
Why would he need qualifiers? Uh like intuitively you could pick
up on on maybe that just means that I find Hassan to be slightly
more palatable. But but the whole premise that I was going with
has been pretty consistent this whole time which is that uh Trump
and Hassan are both so illiberal that uh or Vance and Hassan
are so illiberal that um neither one of those sound like a great
option to me. That's what I mean when I say I'd rather Minecraft.
You understand you can't have that position. And now Pisco for
for Pisco being wanting to be precise and putting up that this
violet touches his own principle and harm reduction.
Pisco will be treated like the Right, but you're but you're unsure
about the disposition on >> Well, he let it go. On my hypotheticals,
Yeah, but that doesn't matter. That's the point I'm making. It
does it really doesn't matter. Like the point is I find them
both to be so illiberal that I would not want to live in a country
that was ruled by either. So I don't know. I I totally agree
with that. I just like the whole thing that Steven is examining
right now is whether I'm good or bad faith. And part of that
um argument from him is that I knew the answer, right? I already
knew the answer. And so, of course, my motivation
when asking the question is to just make you look bad having
like actually knowing the answer. And so presumably I if you're
not even sure, right? Regardless of whether or not and we certainly
do agree that we don't want either of these people leading the
Regardless of whether or not we agree with that and we do.
Whether or not you're sure
is relevant to whether or not I'm good or bad faith. Rather than
the rambling. Okay. If Epstein was the same morally depraved,
okay, child whatever he is now, but Epstein would essentially
be a neoliberal, liberal, defend the liberal world order, whatever,
whatever you would expect him to be. Like you would versus Vance.
And it was that versus Hasan [__] who had decent
control over the government, could sell our secrets, could move
us towards whatever communist ML thing that Hasan would want
to do. Would you rather Epstein or Hasan as president in that
environment? I don't know why we're asking different
than the ones that were actually asked. >> that was the
exact that was the question that was asked.
That's the question. I don't agree.
What's the difference between that question and the one that
was asked before? The question was much more >> out. I'm
out. I just wanted to make You guys were talking about my position,
so Wait, wait, do you but do you do you do you know your position
though?
He probably doesn't want to answer the question because he's
a child question versus Hasan [__] who's been harassing
him for a week on Twitter. No, no, hang on. Just to be clear,
I honestly do not give a [__] about any of that.
That that's all I just don't look at my mentions. It doesn't
it really doesn't phase me. For the most part, 99% of the time
that just doesn't phase me. So it just comes with the territory.
>> you're you're you're wrong about that then, I mean.
You were you were saying that Hutch was was worried about all
his mentions and that that's why he was hesitating and Hutch
just told you that's not the case.
Okay, good job. So, would you Epstein How about an apology? Wait,
wait a second. You're not going to I would never apologize to
you for anything. Oh,
Why? You just say like
Let me just Let me just say something. Hold on. Also, also, also,
just on a base level I have to pause it for 2 seconds. Is Destiny
really saying that posting and calling somebody out for just
just making fun of them on Twitter
is harassment? Is Destiny biting that pill biting that bullet
right now? I think like Destiny, do you not understand uh about
Pesco by now with all the interactions that you've had with him
that he just loves arguing.
No, because he's selectively critical because he selectively
turns on and off understanding depending where he's at in an
argument. The fact that he could perfectly explain earlier why
somebody would choose Epstein over Vance but somehow, you know,
is confused about why would somebody uh you know, have difficulty
answering this question otherwise or you know, exploring the
conversation of why you would need the qualifiers whatever. I
I don't buy that. No, not absolutely not.
You think I selectively
put on I'm out. I think you selectively put on a persona before.
Yeah, 100%. Yeah, of course.
Okay, I don't feel that way. So, Destiny's entire predicate for
this conversation is wrong, totally wrong, and he won't apologize.
He won't do anything else at all. He's just like, "I'll never
apologize to you." Bro, I you just have come on here and proven
to everybody that it is a personal grievance. It's a pet It's
petty personal spite on your behalf. Okay? Get the [__]
out of here, man. Listen, I I mean you did you wouldn't do it,
right?
Well, I mean maybe not but I'm just telling you the truth. Okay,
I mean but you're lying you would say that so you can repeat
that ad infinitum but it doesn't really change the fact of the
matter, right?
I'm not I I guess like
I debate harshly leftists, MAGA people, and libs. I debate That's
just always been my personality. You're a lib, I debated you
very hardcore, and we got into heated heated all the time, and
it was no skin off our back in terms of the the of those dialogues
even when they got vicious um it's it's hard for me to fathom
that um you know when I treat you um similar in terms of our
old debates as I treat Hutch, I think that you'll find there's
absolutely no daylight between those two. And how I treat people
like >> big but the big difference is the is the community
involvement, right? Is I actually Pisco, it's not that you're
any different Pisco. It's not that you've done anything differently.
It's that there are people I don't like involved who watch you.
That's actually where everything Shut
>> were Get the boo. Throw tomatoes at this guy. Get him
off the stage. >> personal saying you were a fake lawyer
uh like the random attacks like that even for liking an Aaron
saying things like Lycan's opinions are influenced by Aaron.
I would generally clamp down on people like that in my community
because I thought it was a bad way to treat somebody that was
on my stream. Destiny himself has said Pisco's opinions are entirely
influenced by Aaron.
Shut the [__] up. You have a person one of your most
frequent chatters is named Rose was 17 implying I'm a me in your
chat. I don't know why you're pretending like the moderation
is the same. It's not just me. These same people when Lonerbox
was on were spamming that he was a genocide apologist, he was
a radical Zionist, he was a Maridite who sat back and watched
in the 80s the the massacres
of people like this is to >> kind of what do you what do
you want to do ban them all? I don't I don't know. Well, no I'm
just like you make that
and entailed in that observation I think is like you're doing
something wrong.
Something has gone horribly wrong here. Yes. Correct. Yes. So,
I'm I'm trying to Is it not crazy to keep saying that Rose was
17 means he's a
I mean, I don't think he really actually cares about being called
a pedo. measures to address it, right?
>> The thing that's gone horribly wrong.
No, of course not. Well, no no I'm I'm asking you I should try
to take corrective measures.
I mean, if you think it's an important thing to correct, but
it could be that you just don't care about it. >> No, mean
like on your view it's an important thing to correct, right?
Yeah, but it might not be on your view. No, but I'm asking your
view. What if I want to protect friendships with the
or the mental sanities or the integrity of the chats in the show
that I'm involved in with co-hosts, I think I probably wouldn't
want people spamming that guest that we're supposedly all on
good terms with >> time Destiny's ever done this by the
way, the only time Destiny's ever done this is for Dan, his one
close actual
And one of the example other examples are people he wants to
These are the only two examples. >> or whatever in general.
I think so, yeah. That's it. Among other things,
I think that um this reminds me a lot of previous conversations
that you had in community with people who would come on stream
and um complain to you about the nature of how they're being
commented in your subreddit or in the chat. And um help me find
the
the through-line there. Because there is some amount of discourse
that you want to allow
but some that you don't. And so help me out, what what is your
North Star?
My North Star was that if I had a chat room that was incessantly
spamming stuff about a particular person that I didn't personally
agree with or that I didn't want to give the impression that
I was condoning, I would do something to clamp down on that in
my chat. What do you think about the concern I have that A and
I kind of like the open people allowed to like make accusations
of in terms of political alignment, like to call people genocide
apologists.
Should that not be allowed? Should it not be allowed to call
someone
Um maybe some things go beyond the pale, but um do you think
that encouraging
there's a place for like encouraging open discourse?
It's not open discourse though. It's not discourse. It's just
people Well, here I'm curious.
Israel's bravest soldier has arrived. Is that person engaging
in discourse?
Sorry, what? >> Hey, look it's the genocide defender Loner
Box. Loner Zionist Box. This guy is an Israel defender. This
guy. Oh, nice Loner Box. He's here to tell us how cool Israel
and that Bibi is totally not doing crimes and we should still
support them. Yeah, look Yeah, Pisco literally Pisco's going
to bite this bullet for sure. That like this person doesn't like
Lonerbox. Yeah,
>> He's a [__] 100%. That's fine. Oh, that's
why Lonerbox loves ethnic cleansing. Lonerbox can can look at
that person and say you're a [__] who would never
come on this and say any of this [__] cuz you'd look
stupid and then talk to them about it. Easy. >> international
law. Lonerbox laughed at sniped Palestinian children and justified
it. He's not a good person. Are these discourse comments? Do
you agree with these comments? I don't know. I don't know. I
don't I don't I don't agree with the comments but they're like
clearly discourse. They're people I didn't ask if you would agree
with the discourse. Okay. So, someone coming in so so from now
on when I'm engaging with you with my chat is I don't really
like Pisco that much. I think he [__] kids. You think
that's good discourse? Are they allowed to have that opinion?
I mean, I think that there's definitely a distinction between
I think that there's a a distinction between, you know, substantive
allegations of misconduct for sure and Oh, by the way, there
it is. There's just he's going to read the chat messages. Told
you, Dessy. Dessy's going to come on. He's going to read the
chat messages, emotionally signal cuz he's a um political No,
no prescription. Just you're really like you're not you're not
like not a good guy. You're like really mean to your friends.
Your friends are like getting talked [__] about and
you won't even do anything about it. Hey, Destiny, have you done
stuff like that? Uh well,
I agree with the things my chat says. No, you don't. No, you
don't and he knows that he's lying there. He knows that people
dude, he knows he's lying about that. >> takes on like
war crimes and [__] it's such a joke. People are
in my chat and was like justifying the incursion >> think
that it's
No, cuz it's a worthless comment. You think it's substantive
to say Lonerbox loves genocide. He's a [__] ghoul.
That's why Lonerbox loves ethnic cleansing. He doesn't believe
in international law. I think he's a Zionist shill and genocide
apologist.
Easily easily discredited comments. The second that person That
person gets called out, says, "Hey, Lonerbox is here. Come in
here and say that to Lonerbox. Try to make those arguments on
stream. Watch how badly you get blown out. When you're that far
away from reality, the solution is bring them on stream. Embarrass
them. >> money and blackmail from his Israel trip and ensuing
drama. I I think the I think the I think the latter I think the
latter part of that ventures into accusations of um you know,
relating to impropriety and misconduct, namely the part about
being paid to go on trips without, you know, any evidence that
it's involved or relates to um actual corruption or Israel payments
or anything like that. And um when somebody I think that's accusations,
but but the genocide stuff can I just want to finish the thought?
I think I'm trying to separate the um comments that are pointed
They're pointed and they're absolutely like derisive and um like
vicious. But they are they do relate to his positions. Now, maybe
they're mischaracterization of his positions. But if someone
said for Yeah, so the genocide thing, it's just like come on
and argue it with him would be my position, right? Come on and
argue with argue with him. >> want to Obvi is a uh Obvi
Bitterman is a genocide apologist that Obvi Bitterman supports,
you know, he doesn't care about international law and is like
a You know, do you think that that is discourse? I think it is.
I think there's a greater degree of truth there about Obvi. I
think Obvi would just say that to some extent. I think Obvi would
say, "I don't give a [__] about international law."
And he might not care if Palestinians are genocide. He seems
to come off as much heavier on the pro-Zionist side. I don't
know what he would say about the genocide. He might just say
that he doesn't believe that there is a genocide. But I do think
Obvi would say that he doesn't give a [__] about
international I think that I think that Obvi would bite the bullet
on international law. But I'm just saying that he's These run
the gamut. These run the gamut. >> you I know you love
that phrase run the gamut. You use run the gamut to box in a
whole bunch of behavior that is not like a whole bunch of other
behavior. These are not comments that are politically engaging
with Lonerbox. These are sick and fake That's Wait, Obvi's run
the gamut. That's not what he used that for. >> That's
from the same Discord that make a ton of accounts spam a whole
bunch of only false statements only false statements about Lonerbox.
Just attack him. They're not here for discourse. >> Steven,
the difference is in terms of someone's interpretation of what
Lonerbox is saying and what Obvi is saying. Now, Obvi, I think
it's a you know, very clear case that I don't give a [__]
about international law. Now, Hold on, do you think there's a
reasonable Do you think there's a reasonable interpretation?
No. Do you think there's He's just going to keep trying to cut
him off. Again, this the whole thing All Destiny wants to do
is go on here and read really unhinged messages and Pisco goes,
"Yeah, I'm going to allow that." So that he can signal that Pisco
is a bad person. That was the entire purpose of coming on today.
He held off doing it cuz I called him on it in the Discord and
now he's just doing it directly.
I said precisely what would happen here. It's so obvious, man.
>> that Luna Box is pro-genocide. No. Uh Then then why
did you just waste your time saying that there are going to be
different interpretations? No, no, because whether or not something
is like a substantive political point doesn't relate to my idea
about whether it's reasonable. Reasonability is like my own notion
about like a given conversation. I don't think it's reasonable,
by the way, that I sweep for tankies. But you allow that discourse.
>> Wait, no, no, I'm asking I'm Well, because you do, but
I but I can justify You're doing it right now. Okay, I think
so. I think so. I think that's unreasonable. I think that's an
unreasonable position. That's fine, but but I can have a substantive
argument about that. For instance, I can point out all of these
comments and I can ask you, do you think that these are discourse
and these are real positions of Luna Box? And you're saying,
well, no, I don't think these are reasonable. Well, some of the
some of the things are some of the things are allegations of
misconduct, namely that he's getting paid, right? So, I did separate
those out. That's why No, you interrupted me. But but I asked
you, do you think him saying he's pro-genocide, do you think
that's a legitimate perspective? That's something that you would
agree with? >> By legitimate do you mean do I agree with
it? No. By legitimate do you mean do you think that it's something
that they could have arrived at through a fair analysis of the
things that Luna Box has said?
Okay, so then how is it discourse? Well, just because it's not
a fair conclusion to draw uh doesn't mean it's not discourse.
I mean, I allow MAGA people to make their arguments about the
election being stolen. I have debates with Rob Noer. I don't
think it's fairly reasonable for him to arrive at given conclusions.
And so, I think this issue is a little bit more difficult than
you're giving it credit for. >> It's not difficult at all.
Those people aren't in your chat arguing that the election was
stolen. So, I'm not talking about people in your chat. >> They do.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, they Okay, wait, so the next time you
talk about election fraud, you think if I stepped into your chat
half the chat would be saying I do think 2020 was stolen? No,
no, that's not what I'm talking about. I'm not talking about
No, I'm not talking about I am talking about the incidents that
are occurring in your chat cuz that's what we were just talking
about. >> we're talking about the nature of what whether
something is a substantive comment relating to discourse or when
it's not. I'm just saying whether or not I think it's reasonable
or a fair, you know, collection of the conclusion based on a
good faith interpretation doesn't mean it's not a substantive
point. And my example of that um relates to the MAGA people.
They're going to align with what you substantively agree with,
no? Says who? Says you. No, I have a lot of
So, you think that the chat a person has should never reflect,
broadly speaking, >> make such an extreme statement. That
it should never >> need to make such a I said broadly.
That was a very general statement. You incredulously asked me,
"Well, no, I don't think that Well, they should reflect my opinion.
I want broad discourse." You're You're appealing to these really
general broad terms. I'm bored by If everyone agreed with me,
I would be bored by that. And like if I if I >> you presenting
this as though I'm telling you to agree with me do you think
that calling loner box a zog box person that that's just a legitimate
political disagreement or saying that loner box supported the
cyber until massacre that these are just political disagreements
and you just want a broad swath of opinions and you do you ever
even confront or deal with any of these opinions? Have you ever
argued ever in your entire life with your chat about whether
or not loner box supports genocide a single time ever? I will
just point out again that Destiny has people actively posting
doxes in his chat constantly.
Doesn't do anything about it. I have never once argued with someone
in my chat about whether having discourse on these it's literally
just a bunch of people that are just [__] going to
make personal attacks. I mean these chats are happening at the
time I'm engaged in a conversation and it uh it's not the case
that I have these long conversations regarding loner boxes opinions
or stated views on genocide although maybe that should lead me
to be like medicine. You know you're asking do you ever have
I'm not telling you to moderate it I'm asking you why do you
think they appear there? Why are they so comfortable and why
are they so prevalent in just your chat? Even Sweet Anita's chat
isn't this bad. Uh hang on a second so I think that they I think
I've already answered this question. The reason that they come
to my chat is A I don't ban them on the basis of their political
view and B because they >> No one has asked me to ban somebody
based on the basis of political view. These are people who are
brigading I've never said I'm sorry what did I say to ban on
political view? Yeah I mean you >> asked you if these are
legitimate political views to have that loner box is a Zionist
I I wait wait wait by legitimate what do you mean? Legitimate
meaning it's fair? By legitimate as in like the person who owns
the streaming platform you it's your stream and it's your chat
I'm asking you if you think that that is a conservative or mega
No but I I have a lot of people with unreasonable takes that
I don't think are fair that I let into my chat. Even though it's
not legitimate on your view which is something approximating
like a fair inference based on all the facts or something.
If I walked into a person's chat and a trans person was on a
YouTube video and every single person in chat
Do you think that I would have a different response if the streamer
themselves said oh my god gross versus another streamer going
oh cool it's a trans person or whatever. Do you think I would
feel a little bit weird in the second example but I can understand
in the first example that in the first example the chat would
be an accurate reflection of the streamer and in the second example
there'd be a very weird schism between what the streamer purports
to believe and what the chat is In the one case in which the
streamer encourages it and one where they're not plus about it
help me out here.
For the two examples. >> think it's reasonable that most
>> want you to reiterate your two examples. But in a world
where the stream chat is highly transphobic but the streamers
themselves seems to be incredibly trans-supportive, I wouldn't
understand that. It'd be very confusing to me. Well, it's possible
that the people who are going to that stream are there for different
reasons and for different opinions or because the streamer encourages
them. What a worthless statement. They go to the stream for different
reasons or for different Do you think it's random what what streamers
people watch? Do you think it's totally random >> saying
it's random. That's That's precisely the opposite of what I'm
You want me to get into it or do you want to just I mean, you
can get into it, but you're just yapping. You're just saying
>> Why am I yapping? I mean You take I mean, like here's
a very pointed question. Do you think that streamer chats tend
to reflect the ideology or perspectives of This is every This
is why you shouldn't talk to this person. This person's [__]
person. Yes or no? I think they tend Okay. And on everything
Did I say on everything?
No, but I'm just putting it out there. Okay, thank you. I mean,
that's good. That's good. Okay, that's cool. Okay, yeah. So,
do you think it'd be really weird if there was a huge division
between what the chat thought about an important topic with the
streamer and with the streamer thought? That'd be a really strange
thing. Depends on what. It depends on the >> opinion of
a political streamer. Um I don't find it that weird, no. Because
for example, I'll give you some examples. Is that okay or do
you want me to stop talking? Give me one example. Give me the
best example you can think of. I stand Merrick Garland. My chat
does not agree with me. They think it's I think that Joe Biden's
pardon of his son was corrupt. Most of my audience doesn't agree
with that.
They disagree with me on um You'd be back on one X. my
Go for it. Let's without using my take on the global entry thing.
They agree with you. They disagree with me on [__]
Okay, let's my Go for it. Let's without using you as an example
cuz a lot of these are confounded by the thing that I'm saying
is a very >> I have to refresh. I have to refresh. I have
to refresh. People have feelings about H3's lawsuit for instance,
so it makes sense that there's going to be diversity That's all
that's weird. If you were to step into another streamer's chat
and the streamer said they were a liberal and half their audience
was MAGA or if they said that they were Yeah, yeah, I'd have
to fix MAGA and half their audience were liberals, like strongly
liberal or strongly MAGA, would that not be confusing to the
majority of people? I think it would be I think it would be confusing
for the majority of people. I'd grant that. Obviously, your numbers
are I don't have any reason to believe your numbers are anything
close to accurate in my case, but yes, I think it would be confusing.
If you had to guess on an episode of Left and Learn, on the one
with Lonerbox, what percentage of the comments do you think were
like highly hostile towards Lonerbox and Hutch? If you had to
ballpark it. I'm not going to ask you for a specific but you
just said that >> chat or overall?
Uh from your chat.
if I had to guess
probably
a plurality of the comments
were critical
of of Hutch. I think a lot of people who don't like Hutch
congregate to my chat.
And you think that's just because you allow a wide range of discourse?
Do you think the people that are critical of Hutch are critical
to Hutch in a way that is constructive or destructive?
Destructive. And you don't care about that at all? It doesn't
No, I care about >> impact you at all? That's why I have
a conversation with Hutch when he when he requested it. That's
why I try to I always
try to tell my audience that we this is this is all just debates,
it's all just discussions and that um we agree on way more. That's
why I take opportunities to agree with him. Do you think that
your community was warmer or colder towards him at the end of
the 3 and 1/2 hour talk you had?
Sure. I think that it's probably the case that they're colder
to him and I think part of that has to do with
how long it was and how
um it seemed that we were it was tough for us to get common ground.
Um I'm sure that's I So you have you've got a community that's
already a plural
plurality of them are I was just thinking about that. It's just
very frustrating. It's frustrating watching this because it's
like so obvious that none of this is done in good faith. It's
like, yeah, my community is more frustrated after Hutch refused
to accept a basic
a basic logical inference.
You would vote for Epstein, obviously. Or you or you were wrong
or lying about something before. Pick one. Either say you vote
for Epstein or say what you were lying about about from before.
And it's like lying or uh you know, emotional bias misspoke on
before. Clear up the the inconsistency way. And you have a conversation
where explicitly the goal is to warm your community up to Hutch,
and they come away from that even >> the goal. Wait, no,
that wasn't the goal. That's a perverse goal. The goal was to
you know, Hutch wanted the conversation. I wanted to engage with
him in good faith, and
I'm just having the conversation. I don't really have another
ulterior motive. Okay, so do you have any desire whatsoever for
your chat to reflect broadly the opinions and views you have
of either your politics or the people around you or Yes, I do.
Okay, so then when the majority or when a plurality of them seem
to be destructively critical of people that they should understand
the most, right? Like Hutch, I'm guessing is one of the people
you do the most content with. So, they should be the one of the
people they understand more than anybody else. Do you guys remember
when Pisco would have debated Destiny on on January 6th?
I would just wonder if we could find like all of the comments
about Pisco from that January 6th debate. The very first one
where he disagreed very very very harshly with Destiny. Or the
the self-defense one. I wonder what the comments in DGG would
be like about Pisco.
I wonder if they would be constructive, largely constructive.
What do you guys think they'd be like? Hmm, isn't that an interesting
conversation? Like we all have to sit here and pretend that we
don't know exactly how all these communities operate, how they're
all like pretty extreme, there's a lot of people saying extreme
things, and that Destiny for a very long time had no concern.
Maybe he's got concern now that he's got people to talk about
with him. Maybe he's got concern about how communities treat
other people. But it's not born from a place of good faith. It's
not born from a place of like he he principally agrees with this.
He principally agrees you have to defend your friends from from
your chatters. That's not it.
Doesn't it signal that there's some critical failing there? Not
necessarily, no. Well, but so help me break down cap on that.
What what besides a critical failing of communicating your feelings
and beliefs to your audience could explain why the plurality
of them are destructively critical towards one of your podcast
I think oftentimes um people react emotionally to different arguments
and different sort of setups. And the mere fact that Hutch and
I are engaging in an antagonistic
thing sometimes when cuz we did we differ on some key issues.
Irrespective of the fact that I think that ultimately it's good
like um back and forth Uh we don't we don't talk Hutch tonight,
okay? Hutch came in and even though it would have been incredibly
easy for Hutch to come in and say like, "Man, Pisco, you were
really mean to me." He didn't do that. He came in and said, "Actually,
like this was my opinion and now I'm going to leave." Okay? He
could have very easily come in and I I personally wasn't sure
how to think about it cuz I do think Hutch is somebody who values
his friendships and Pisco is his friend. So I I had faith, okay?
I had some faith.
But it would have been so easy for him to just lean into, "Actually,
Pisco, you're being really mean to me." and just sue or Pisco.
And he didn't do >> worth that it um can be valuable sometimes.
I I I don't think it's necessarily a failure And by the way,
no matter who you are, okay? No matter who you are, when you
have a fight with somebody and then other people are making fun
of you for it, you do kind of blame them. You would be kind of
mad at them. Hutch almost certainly has that feeling a little
bit. Like, "Pisco, you did something bad to me." But he didn't
indulge that feeling at all. He decided to hold it back and and
not sue his friend in front of like a whole bunch of viewers,
which I
Because I don't think that feeling is reasonable. You feel that
even if you're in the wrong, you feel like the other person kind
of [__] you over.
But he he was actually measured. He didn't do that. He didn't
just lean into >> I live and learn that we get into those
situations, but the mere fact that we do get into those situations
um might tend
um cause
certain destructive comments, notwithstanding um a lack of failure
in the overall scheme of the show. Do you think that you have
a healthier or more politically informed discord in your chat
than in any of the other live and learn chats? I'm not sure I
don't go to their chats. Wait, so you have no concept of what
any other chat looks like at all? You're just But you >> Only
only when I'm in Hutch's chat, which is probably once every couple
weeks. What's up, dude?
Well, I I mean the I mean >> You really think I'm just
trying to [__] over Hutch because I want to be best
friends with Destin?
I'd never said that in my entire life. >> just asking like
what what what what do you think I'm doing?
I don't know sometimes. To be honest, I don't think No, I don't
think it's for money. I've never said that. That's another delusion
you've either crafted or been told by somebody else. I don't
>> Then I must be crazy. You must think I'm like literally
crazy. No, I think you're very ego-driven and somewhat kind of
a huge piece of [__] And personally, I think it's
insane to me that you could sit in a chat and Dude, how do you
not feel I could never? I could never. I could never. I could
never be this shameless. In my entire life, I could never be
this shameless. That is an insane thing to say.
watch your chat just tear into people like Lonerbox or Hutch
to have like the only actual liberals on the internet on the
show Live and Learn while there's like a creepy weirdo tankie
cult ran by a queen of agistical that are openly and obviously
talking in your Discord, making mobile accounts in your YouTube
chat, and you sit here and say, "Well, it's in the defense of
discourse that people are making fun of Lonerbox's ethnicity
to say he's a >> Not again. That's That's That's against
That's against I would ban that person.
I Unfortunately for Destin on this one, Lonerbox has literally
talked to me. I've literally pointed out every time somebody
does the Lonerbox's dad was a Maronite thing, I go, "No, Lonerbox's
dad was not a Maronite. Don't even say it jokingly. It's just
not true. It's obviously not true." >> I I I would ban
you. You won't be You won't be You won't be banned. Any of I
mean, apparently all of the all of these >> definitely
I will I will ban I will [laughter] ban people who
Pisco, you have to ban Cattie? Pisco, ban Cattie now. Pisco,
ban Cattie now. >> ban It's not It's not about bullying.
What is the chat? >> should be the The question should
be, why do you draw those people? I don't know why should that
be the
Because because it says something about your character if those
are the types of people you attract and nobody else around you
seems to attract that audience. It says something. I literally
have to say as a as a caveat every time I'm like, I know some
I know you a lot of you guys aren't going to like this, but I
agree with LunarBox. I know a lot of you guys aren't going to
like this, but I defend LunarBox. I know a lot of you guys aren't
going to like this, but no, you're actually wrong about LunarBox
here. I do it all the time, constantly. >> Now, it might
be that you genuinely don't care or that you support their comments
or you think they should be allowed to flourish or whatever.
I allow hateful comments of myself in my in my chat in my YouTube
comments. I >> that's the same thing? No, I don't think
it's the same thing, but it's just to show you that um I'm not
just trying I'm not trying to cultivate a community that um agrees
with me all the time. It's my wish that they would, Why do you
keep saying that? It's not about agrees with you. You're not
cultivating a community that is having genuine political disagreement.
They're just sh- on and destructively attacking everybody around
Yeah, so >> was full of a bunch of people who were saying
like, I think LunarBox's reading of the last Israeli thing I
think it was crazy. I think LunarBox's opinion on Gaza is [__]
up. I don't think LunarBox gives enough on on war crimes that
Israel's doing. That's fine. That's those are perspectives. I
think that's But I think that's different in kind from what you're
saying. They run the gamut. I think it's different in kind from
what you're saying. They run I'm not agreeing with you because
you you use this phrase called run the gamut where you pretend
>> There's a range of sh- that like There's something that's
clearly different in kind. It's a different thing in kind. >> Just
Just bully Just bully Pisco until he agrees with you. And you
seem to either be intentionally misunderstanding that or you
just don't seem to understand that. What I'm trying to tell you
when I say those that the spectrum stuff is there are clear cases
and there are unclear cases. There are some comments that um
I think are more ambiguous in terms of whether they're responding
to to substantive political points or whether they're uh trolls
or whether they're attempting to ascribe, you know, malicious
accusations of misconduct and that it's a little bit more complicated
I think that you're letting on. And I just like I I I look back
and I think about all the different times people raise these
concerns with you to fold it up to fold their arms. And um I
think that maybe >> the thing is and we can talk about
those and I understand you've been told by all these people about
Mr. Girl. If you want, we can go and revisit any one of those
things. I know that you know what you're saying is because I
know that you know for instance Dan is unhinged and obsessed
and I know you have watched me personally multiple times when
Dan is saying some crazy [__] about you go I don't
do that I don't we're not
Uh this is just a lie. This is just a lie. This is just a lie.
He's obviously lying right now.
Dude, Destiny was literally in his chat saying that straight
away it is like this guy.
Repeatedly. What are we talking about
Oh wait, he might have actually blamed Joanna for it too. >> I know
that you know that I've banned people posting on my subreddit.
I've banned people making threats on that. That I made personal
interventions for weird comments about liking an Erin despite
the fact that I can't stand either of them, right? Despite the
fact that both of them are part of other groups whatever. I still
don't allow those comments. So you can try to say that like well
because of this and you're really just I'm pretty sure you're
just referring to the Mr. Girl stuff because that's what people
told you. When Mr. Girl was banned from my subreddit he made
700 posts I think in like a week and then my mod temp banned
him and then he lost his mind on it. But I I don't know how you
can say how you can claim what what is an issue that you think
I've never I don't get it perfect all the time but I'm always
trying to moderate my community. What is a topic that you think
I just totally let run rampant in my community. Yeah, so whenever
in the past 10 years. He will be fully down that road in 6 months.
What did this guy say what is his tree 44? Again, I wouldn't
jump to conclusions calling Destiny a sped and and Dan a white
blood cells weird as [__] but in terms of his motivations
and opinions I think he's more just mad at Tiny Dan DGG for attacks
rather than being an anti-fan and then Destiny says he will be
fully down that road to being an anti-fan or a communist in 6
months. Hang out with Erin plus becoming ingratiated with that
community means it's inevitable. Literally Erin is this guy.
Erin is turning this guy into a communist. I never I never ever
support those kinds of narratives in my chat guys. You lying
What a loser man. >> This comes on here and lies brazenly.
Um certain people you know begging you to do one thing or another
with your community and Discord. As I said here For what one
thing what
As I hit here as I said here um maybe there's this the lab lab
lab loon or someone like that as I recall but again Yeah, I said
know I've talked to Lav before but I can't I can't stop But also
keep in mind Lav was the most instigatory aggressive person on
the internet. I did delete threads at least one thread for Lav.
I'm sure my community knows about it. For all the unhinged criticism
against Lav who I think is a subhuman piece of [__]
but there are still a lot of people who are misogynistic against
her. I did on multiple times tell my community, "Hey, we're not
going to make misogynistic comments." So like yeah you you can
point to people being mean but I don't think that that's the
same as saying I've let these people go crazy and run around
making threads. Steven, it's possible that that's a wrong impression
as I sit here and I I But also wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
I know I know but I just want to say this too. Your comparison
was Lav who has sought and leaked revenge porn of me has talked
[__] about me sent all sorts of crazy [__]
This is like my one of my mortal
It's bad. Lav is bad. [__] enemies and you're using
that You were literally on a Food Shop's call with her like 4
months ago. Was he not on a Food Shop's call with her like 4
months ago again talking to her? She's one of my mortal enemies.
person for how you let your chat treat Hutch. Yeah, I know so
like So I I think I'm referring to a time period in which that
wasn't the case.
I think that's I don't think that's ever happened. Okay. I'm
As I sit here I'm I'm happy to say that I don't have specific
examples to bring up with you that I have instant recall
but either way it's just like not my motive to [__]
with Hutch and so maybe like I have a different view on moderation
and Dev gave me some things to think about with respect to
the kind of like consistent standard for and so I genuinely will
think about that and I'm not saying that I'm perfect. I invite
I just want to be I want to be clear. I invited I invited DGG
moderators to come join the moderation team. It's not like I'm
avoiding suggestions. I'm just asking for suggestions and that's
why I find it weird that you're >> But you're not and that's
why I've read those conversations that where you do the sticking
thing of like so should I ban this thing? You're totally missing
the point. >> rule? What do you want the What do you want
the rule to be? You're not You're not If If If you had a If you
had a boyfriend or girlfriend or friend and you would hang out
with their friend group and as soon as you walked in you heard
all of them say, "I hate Pisco. I hate his eyebrows. He's [__]
Would you Would you say to your friend I'm not saying that. Could
you just tell them, "No, no. >> I'm going to I'm going
[__] I'm going to [__] lose it cuz I
swear to god there are people saying things like, "Man, I just
I just wish there wasn't so much drama in the Pisco community
while being like openly DGGers." I just wish there I'm sorry.
If there's a purge, it should go in the other direction, okay?
>> you wouldn't have a problem with the problem and you're
like, "I don't know. You know, do you want me to just tell them
not to make comments about your eye >> do call some people
out. I don't get to everything just like you don't get to everything,
I'm sure.
No, you just don't read your read your chat. You just said you
don't read your chat. No, I don't No, I don't say I never No,
I don't say I never read my chat. I said on Liven Learn when
I'm going to engage with like four or five other people, [__]
gets through, you know? A couple things get through and I'm and
I think that there are some things that you described there that
would be bannable, 100%. >> things. It's like half the
chat. Okay, I mean, show me specific things and I'll go I'll
go back to the VOD that's linked and I'll take a look at it.
But what's It's not about going It's not about going back to
the VOD. >> What should I do? Tell me what to do. >> No, tell
me what to tell me the I want the prescription. How to solve
it? It's one of those things where you if you have to say it,
it it doesn't it doesn't really matter. It doesn't count. If
you have to say it, why are you saying it? Because it's like
reminding a significant other about Valentine's Day or something.
It just doesn't doesn't mean much. Or to say something like,
"Hey, could you compliment me right now cuz I need words of affirmation?"
You're like, "Oh, okay." I saw his Discord this time. It's his
like chats. Destiny's relitigating all the same points he did
before and he's going to end up in the same place where he's
not going to make a recommendation cuz he is a whiny weepy But
it doesn't really hit the same way. It doesn't work at that point,
right? If you don't have an actual desire No, I I I don't want
to make Hutch I don't want to make Hutch uncomfortable. I have
that No, no. If you don't have a desire for your chat to reflect
the feelings that you have to some extent towards other people,
at least in non-destructive ways, that just says a lot about
I guess what you're willing to put forward into the world. That's
just a It's a very insane thing to me. It doesn't seem to be
reflected in almost any other streamer's chat that I'm aware
of. Certainly nobody in your sphere.
I mean, uh I don't know, dude. I I We've had this like moderation
conversation internally and we've had stuff with um with you
and with um other people messaging me that we should like immediately
ban certain individuals and certain Why do you keep jumping >> that?
Why do you keep saying that? Immediately ban ban ban ban ban.
The reason I go there is because I'm trying to solve an issue.
Is that the only thing you know for how to moderate a community?
Is to is to ban people. I'm I'm I'm requesting more guidance
from people who know better, who claim to know better like you.
I think that the way that you interact with people and I think
that what you allow in
>> I'm asking for a prescription from you. I think that
the way you interact with people Shut the [__] up.
>> to your community
about the types of behavior that's allowed. Okay, Marco Rubio.
I think we should dispel the fiction that Barack Obama doesn't
know what he's doing. He knows exactly what he's doing. When
you're blown out of a point, you just restate your original premise.
Very >> that you found it necessary every time to ask for
a recommendation about Ethan or Destiny stuff that you banned
him from your Discord, but the fact that that same rule for some
reason didn't seem to carry over to your Twitch chat or YouTube
chat is kind of strange. Why was it so bothersome in one area,
but not in the other area? >> I'll tell you why. Because
we didn't have a Destiny snark problem in the Discord. That wasn't
a problem. That's something you invented. That's something I
invented.
>> It's not true. We didn't have a Destiny snark problem.
Most of my people in my Discord are are fans of yours.
If I go to your Discord right now, am I going to see Just a cool
saying things
I don't think that or or it's almost like Destiny just wants
to come in and show a bunch of bad logs from Peace Coast's chat
to try to emotionally signal that he's not in here with a whole
bunch of his other friends, Carmel and everything else. That's
it. You literally did that. You literally did that. You literally
did that though. >> that in the Discord. If he If he's
done that in the Discord, he'll be banned because there's a there's
a rule against that now. That's rule 16. I know that it was that
it was that he was he was reminded of that, but they're in there.
All of them are in there. What I'm trying to say is that rule
wasn't to resolve a problem. It was to resolve the perception
of a problem. Okay. We don't have We don't have a Destiny snark
problem. All of those same people You say you don't have a Destiny
snark problem. One of your most frequent Twitch chatters is called
Rose with 17. Yeah. So, the problem, I think, is when it's in
Discord and it's like behind there's this feeling that we're
all like cultivating whatever.
Yeah, it's a reference to you for sure. Okay, being right. Um
yes. Okay, but you don't have a snark
Well, I think the the existence of a snarker in my chat doesn't
constitute Do you think there's just one? What about all the
Kathy accounts? Do you think those are just to go related? What
about the Duby donations? Duby is from the discord. Duby is I
mean Duby donates to Connor unless you think that Connor has
a snark problem. These people these people These people go to
These people go to Yeah, come on. Come Cuz Connor wants to get
into it. These people in the chat and they go to his chat. Connor
likes these people. You let them run roughshod over everybody.
I
With respect to what? With respect to what? JD dancing politics
and socialism or with respect to >> about other streamers
and other Everybody knows Connor's positions on it and he knows
what he allows and doesn't allow in his chat. But these people
don't even try in Connor's chat because they know it's not No,
but you don't really have Do you have a problem with Duby being
in Connor's in Connor's chat?
No, because Connor makes his position and stance on all these
things clear and he doesn't hide behind this veneer of the behavior
runs the gamut and well, I like lots of discourse. That discourse
can also happen to be calling people Zionist genocide supporters
and
Okay, so you think that the the Destiny rule 16
should be applied in the chat but not for other people, right?
Well, I'm asking you. I'm asking you. You said it's weird it's
not applicable Well, no, no, no, I'm not playing this game because
I'm not I'm not so easily
I By the way, literally everything I said, if I get banned from
Pisco's discord, it's for being correct, okay? It's just for
being correct. I said he will have no recommendation, there will
be no prescription. He just wants to come on and read bad messages
that were in Pisco's chat so that he could try to paint Pisco
as a bad person. He did exactly what I said and then felt no
shame about reading that message on stream to try to get me banned
from Pisco's discord. So
embarrassing, man. >> question. What rules are on your
game? It's It is a trick. >> You just want to keep repeating
why are they there? Why are they there? Why are they there? Why
are they there? That's a loop. That's a loop. It's a loop because
you're not answering the question honestly. You keep saying,
"Well, cuz I think that I allow a lot of discourse. This isn't
discourse. Okay. You said yourself that you think that discourse
is destructive. That's not discourse. It's just [__]
on people. Destructive criticism is snarking. Here's what I think
why I think a lot of Destiny haters show up to my chat. Is because
A, I'm not afraid to disagree with you. B, I'm not afraid to
call out people that they think are enemies. And C, a lot of
them I think that there is overlap between a lot of them and
leftist communities and they liked what I've had to say about
And oh, hold on. No, no, no, hold on. There's a D.
They liked what I've had to say about Ethan Klein's lawsuit.
That's what I think. Yes. Yep.
That's all accurate. >> think that any of it is intentional
brigade behavior from >> but I'm not covering but the thing
is how does that make sense because I'm not
I watch Pisco in my free time.
I literally watch Pisco. When I want a context on something,
I watch Pisco.
Do you think that I go out to you I don't do that. >> you
don't have to. You don't have to do it. The chat does it for
you. I don't engage with that. He's He's literally fulfilling
the market demand. Yes, for a
for a best liberal commentator
who can get in debates and throw elbows. Boom. That's all I wanted.
I just wanted somebody who wasn't, you know, mining his audience
for contacts. Thank god I found one. Same thing with I might
as well ban >> people who engage with it, yeah. Oh, now
we're going to do the should I ban it? Should I ban every message
about this? What do you want me to do? Align more with you and
and >> Yes, you have to agree with me on everything. Yes.
I'm asking what what is it that You're saying I don't want to
give any prescription whatsoever, right? I have an incredibly
negative opinion of you and I have had for a while. If you go
into my chat, are people saying things like um like I don't even
know what personal accusations people would make about you because
we don't even we don't even engage in that here. People might
call you at like the worst like people would say oh, he's a piece
of [__] he's a Nazi. Maybe call him like a grifter
or he's trying to build a left wing or whatever, but we still
would ban the um the fake lawyer comments. We'd speak out about
that. If somebody says something uh super egregious or unhinged
even about like an Aaron, right? People in chat will say something
like well, hold on. what know about The unfortunate Yeah, they're
literally doxing people. Even though I have a credibility issue
with him, he doesn't want to litigate that, but they're literally
doxing people in his chat. Now, you don't have to have that same
opinion, that's fine, but I don't like the playing ignorant or
stupid about it.
Okay. Because they're not here because I'm like snarking on you,
you grant
No, but they're there because they know they can snark, and it's
one of the things that that keeps at least some of that crowd
around because they know that they're able to go in there and
they're able to post those comments. If if there aren't people
coming in from Destiny's community where Destiny is picking this
fight with Pisco, right? Destiny says Pisco should be kicked
off of his own show. Are those people talking about Destiny randomly
all the time? Or are they just engaging in the community normally,
too?
I know the answer to that. They're all there for Pisco's commentary.
I know that cuz I get [__] annoyed when Pisco's live
at the same time as me, okay? If I'm trying to do politics and
Pisco goes live and is doing the same politics, I lose viewers.
I get [__] annoyed about it.
uniquely in your chat now. Sorry, I'm yelling for no I'm not
yelling for any particular reason, but
snarking generally. I think that the concern on snarking though,
as you've expressed it and certainly as you sir priorly expressed
it, is for particular snarking on particular people. I don't
think you have a problem with snarking Hasan, snarking Ethan
Klein really that much on certain issues. We don't do we don't
typically do we don't do I mean like I don't even know how much
we can snark Hasan for. I mean, we'll do the the I guess the
bro Bro, you don't believe this. Come on, man. Speak plainly.
You don't you don't believe that. Let me say it plainly. First
of all, shut the [__] up, okay? Um number one, number
two, like if we do, it's just because this guy has engaged in
such an unfathomable level of snark against me, including doxing
me, including every single time he references me, he calls me
"Pessiny" and "Siny Peto Siny" or whatever. And it's like reading
down my TV farm thread on stream. So, we might do a little bit
of snark against Hasan. Um but even even for these people, like
I we tend to look
Doc, you literally said that Ethan Klein his kids, you loser.
You dox people constantly.
a certain type of thing, right?
Um Like most of the complaints that we have against Hasan, like
you can watch my chat during the Hasan and Adam Molgler thing.
Almost all of the complaints were political.
With respect to Maucler or with Hasan? With respect to Hasan.
Yeah, I mean I I have no doubt about that. In the moment. >> not
it's not like our So it's not even most of our comments about
Hasan are usually ones of like political hatred. Like that's
how we engage with him substantively almost all the time. I think
that's an overstatement. I mean, in the context of a debate,
I understand that, you know, you're saying that, but um but but
you're saying that conceptually sort of Sh- Sharp's breaking
the programming, okay? Um Sharp's breaking the programming. He
literally said on stream that you'd be gone by the end of the
Yeah, that is what he said. It seems like he's going to try to
make that prediction come true any way he can. >> As a
philosophical or principled matter,
encouraging snarking is bad.
Generally speaking,
>> By the way, where have I in any of the stuff I've criticized
Destiny or the community for in this entire conversation, where
have I like referenced Destiny being a to make an
By the way, I I don't even believe Destiny's But where have I
said anything like that? Where have I brought up his court cases?
I don't do any of that. The whole time it's just been substance
the entire time. Speaking But also keep in mind, again, we're
going to comparisons between Why does Pisco always leave out
the strongest point? Because
Pisco genuinely, I think, is uninformed on some of these points.
He's actually not entirely informed on the drama, and he wants
to just answer the the >> Like my mortal enemies who have
doxed me, have done infinite amounts of personal attacks against
me, against my family, right? And I'm talking about how your
co-hosts that you were supposed to be friendly with are treated,
right? That's the comparison that you keep running to.
What about his co-host for his previous show, Starlight? How
about her? Yeah, no, I'm not trying to to run >> Did he
engage in protectionism for Starlight that he didn't with Hutch?
>> um to any place or to try to say that I moderate >> Wouldn't that
be the question? Um they're That's not what I'm saying. Was it
a problem? What a weird that I'm not >> No, I'm not saying
about it being perfect. You said you were indifferent to it.
No, I didn't say that I'm indifferent to it. That's a lie. You
did. You said you don't moderate it. You're asking, "Well, what
do I ban?" Right? You know, you're No, it's a It's a lie to say
that I'm It's a It's a a say that I'm indifferent towards negative
comments or my co-hosts. That's not true. Really? Because it
seems like every time they point it out and you read them, they're
running through your chat to attempt to find it or whatever and
90% of the time you even ban the person. I think the last two
times I watched you try to chase a comment down and even ban
the person. People in your own chat even remark, "Wow, why are
so many people here so keen towards Hutch or whatever?" because
they can't seem to understand it sometimes. And they're not making
like Yeah, okay. critical comments. As you yourself said earlier,
the majority of them are destructive. >> Mhm. Mhm. Mhm.
>> So, I think that a lot of the people who engage with
Hutch's commentary in my comments are kind of doing like
critiques of Hutch. Not all though. I mean, there's a lot of
I think critiques of Hutch that I agree with. But on on certain
given days, you know, I'll see a lot of like Hutch is stupid,
Hutch is this and that. I will see that of me on other chats
as well. But I'm going to be honest with you, Steven, it feels
like on that view, um at least as pertains to me, and maybe you
say it's different because he's my co-host and I'm not your co-host
or anything. Feels like DGG sometimes is a piece of [__]
or something. And when you cover every single live and learn
episode and just talk [__] and
and constantly talk [__] about my motives, I'm doing
this for money, that's what the chat says about the audience.
You got to you have to you have to you can't talk with lines
of substance or whoever has given them to you. I don't think
I've ever said you do this for money. I'm pretty sure when I'm
asking I'm talking about [laughter] your motivations, that's
one of the things I'm most confused about. I don't think you
ever are optimizing for money or audience or whatever. I don't
understand like that you have this incredibly negative view of
how I moderate the community, that I'm doing it for some nefarious
purpose. What purpose? I mean, what makes sense of that for me?
I don't know. I I truly I truly have no idea. For somebody who
is so upset about Ethan claiming you were a fake liar, for you
to stand by and watch the most insanely unhinged chat comments
fly by about your co-hosts. That's I don't I don't understand
it. I think there's some degree of audience capture. I think
the biggest part is probably Audience capture is is is like grifting
stuff. Audience capture is like I'm telling them things I don't
believe. It could be that you that you know that if you do a
certain I think I think that if you want to call it bad faith,
then fine. But I think if you had to reset your brain and you
had an episode of live and learn and you glanced over at your
chat and you glanced half of them giving destructive criticism
towards Hutch, I think you'd go, "Wait, hold on guys, what the
[__] I don't think this is about Hutch. I don't hate
I have said the same thing. In fact, in the very in in in the
very podcast Wait a second. Wait No, no, no. In the in the very
podcast Come on, here. Oh, look, it's Ryan Beard. He says Lonerbox
of Destiny is a Zionist. Oh. In the very podcast episode you
said, I remember it clearly. There were people going after Hutch
and Jose saying, "Oh my god, these guys talking about Kamala
Harris, they just want to lose the election." I stopped everything
to say, "You guys going after Hutch and Jose, they're just reading
polls. You guys are acting like babies, and that's [__]
up." I do this, and I don't Maybe I should do it more, but it
seems like people the more you do it will think it's condescending
and not Oh, no, no, no, you can't do that cuz then then you'd
be leaving Destiny on an island where where Destiny is the one
who somebody says, you know, Rose 117, and you won't correct
that cuz you don't want to talk about the Nazi L.
I can't be the one who you want to see in chat. But also, those
aren't even remotely close to the types of comments that I was
talking about earlier. I think that those were the types of destroy
destructive comments. I think anybody else around you would probably
be much happier for it.
I mean, I don't know, dude, like those comments were that I'm
referencing right now were pretty bad faith interpretations of
what Hutch was saying, um pretty like stupid and inane. I'm looking
at something in the general I'm looking at something in the general
chat in the pisscord. That image or album, okay? It's not It's
just a few comments for I sent it to him like like 2 minutes
ago. It's within our Is this images of the chat in the pisscord?
No, no, but is this images of the Discord and the general chat?
Of the chat messages. During live and learn. Hey, look, it's
genocide defender Lonerbox, Israel's bravest soldier, has arrived.
Loner Zionist box. This guy's an Israel defender. This guy Oh,
nice, Lonerbox thinks that's how cool Israel and the BB are or
not doing war crimes. We should still support them despite 80%
of Democrats supporting the policy. Yeah, Lonerbox loves genocide,
it's cool, man. That's why Lonerbox loves ethnic cleansing, he
doesn't believe in international law. Lonerbox laughed at sniper
Palestinian children and justified it. He's not a good person.
Not denying the sniper laughing allegations, though. Lonerbox
is a genocide defending piece of [__] And then he's
using him to defend
And you're not going to like the
I mean, what's the point? You're refusing to give any kind of
I uh I just went and pasted the Wikipedia article. Uh wait, hold
on. I'm just I'm just pulling up this Wikipedia article on Cassandra
for no particular reason, okay? Just no particular reason.
Just pulling up the uh relates to a person whose valid warnings
or concerns are disbelieved by others. I'm just pulling this
up totally unrelated to anything, okay? Just totally unrelated.
Oh, you put it You put an immature album in Pisco's Discord to
make your point. Oh, well.
I guess the question is when you look at these the two questions
are is one, how much of these do you agree with? And then two,
how much of these represent a thought process that you think
is valuable to discourse in your community? I don't agree with
these comments. I don't have a basis to believe that um Voter
Box is a Zionist. I don't frankly spend a lot of time looking
at Voter Boxes uh Israel positions. Um maybe he's a Zionist.
Whether he defends genocide I think his view is that it's not
a genocide. Um that's his view, right? I think that we've DM'd
about that that he But you're asking me to No doubt maybe he
is a What do you mean when you No doubt no doubt. What are you
interpreting that to mean? Wait a second wait a second. You're
you're asking me to evaluate You're asking me to evaluate the
truth of these claims. I'm telling you I don't know >> No,
I said how much of these do you agree with? Do you agree with
it? When somebody says so for example somebody says cuz you're
I'm just I want to hear your thought Wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait. You just acted like that was different.
I'm you're asking me to evaluate my sense of whether these are
true. Correct, yeah. Well true I mean if you agree with them.
You can't give ground at all even with the No no no no no no
no no no no this is it's not crazy at all. I just mean is true
or you agree with them it can be interpreted in different ways.
I'm just clarifying what you said. Okay? When somebody says loner
Zion These words against me loner Zionist box. Are you when you
think like well maybe loner box is a Zionist what do you think
Zionist means there? How do you think they mean
In its normal usage Zionist Zionism
Well how else am I Maybe I'm ignorant I don't No no no no it's
a political the state of Israel No no no it is I don't know wait
wait wait wait. No, an ideological Zionist is one who's committed
uh to the project of of the um land in in Palestine. Or in mandatory
Palestine or in the Levant or however you want to say or greater
Israel. Committed ideologically.
people's ideologies are like the world views and if someone is
part of their world view is dedicated to the existence of a Jewish
land in um Okay. In today's political climate I don't know how
many conversations you've had at this point. When somebody calls
you a Zionist especially in a derogatory manner especially in
a political conversation Oh, they're going to relitigate the
they're going to relitigate the definition of Zionist to make
it really evil to call Voter Box a Zionist. Okay, got it. that
you think that Jews have a right to genocide or ethnically cleanse
Palestinians with no recourse and that the rest of the world
should either support them or stand by and watch.
I think that's not what I'm implying. When they in this context,
you don't think so? I think those are other views that the person
probably has, I'm going to guess, but um that's not what the
term Zionist means. It's use use use, not prescription description,
right? We go by how people use the words, right? >> Yeah,
I I think people use the term Zionist sometimes as a dog whistle
for
If you were listening to people talking and somebody said, "Oh,
he's a Zionist." Would you assume that they're simply describing
a political position with no normative difference? Unless I have
other facts about the person that I know to be anti-Semitic or
something, I would assume that they're referring to Zionism in
a derogatory sense.
Okay, and probably some of the logical extensions of that, namely
the supporting of the genocide like for example, it'd be really
weird for somebody to say, "Oh, that guy he's a Zionist, but
I think he thinks that the that the Palestinian treatment is
a genocide." That'd be a really weird sentence. Generally speaking,
you wouldn't hear that combination with "Oh, he's a Zionist,
but he's really against the genocide of the Palestinians." Right,
what do you suggest that the Zionist term here is meant to say
that he's a genocide defender? Yes, it's not a good faith assessment
of what he's not even trying to be a good faith assessment of
what he says. He's just result of calling him like a genocidal
maniac, a genocidal freak. So, if you guys think if you think
that Israel's doing a genocide and Lonerbox says they're not
doing a genocide, to you in your frame Lonerbox is a genocide
denier and you that is a good faith critique. >> So, when
leftists call people Zionist, you think they're uniformly stating
that um those people are genocide apologists. Yes, of course,
obviously.
They believe that, it's a good faith argument from them. It is
awful, like it's an awful thing to call somebody, but they believe
it. It is a good faith >> are other comments that just
explicitly say that, so I don't know. That's not my interpretation
of how the term is used. >> that's not what he's saying.
People say Well, of course, there's a variety of ways that people
say the same thing, of
Do you think that the guy was merely describing that he's committed
ideologically to the existence of the state of Israel when he
calls him Loner Zionist Box? He's just saying that into a vacuum.
>> he's saying he's an Israel defender. I think that's
what he's suggesting. Defender of what? What is he really defending
for right now? Against charges of genocide. Among other things,
war crimes, among the also the >> so he supports all those
things, right? That's what the comment means. Well, again, it
could that person have other views, but by itself I don't take
that maybe it's a signal of all the other views that they have.
It's in a It's in a chat with a whole bunch of other people spamming
the same type of stuff. So Now now we're going to move the goal
post to Pisco wasn't able to agree with me on my definition.
That shows just how deranged he is. He's basically straight away.
He's a Marxist-Leninist himself. That's where we're going to
move the goal post to. Okay, we couldn't win on any of the substance
before this, any of the original critiques got blown the [__]
out on all of it. So now we dragged it to this place where we're
going to go oh well, he couldn't agree that Zionists is used
as like a pejorative to say genocide defender. As like okay,
dude. I guess. I guess so. No, I think I'm just more interested
in your feelings about it. The prescription is easy, it naturally
follows. But if you don't think anything is a problem, then there
is no prescription cuz why would you want one?
I'm not chicken.
Because you're trying to pretend that you have either no ability
to influence your community or that all of these comments just
run a wide gamut of
You already have special rules for me. I don't need special rules
for Destiny. I just get sad to watch you treat your co-host on
your show like [__] in a way that none of the other
chat
Yeah, I think really sad. It's supposed to be one of the only
lib spaces on on Twitch or whatever. So watching your entire
chat It's not. He's doing the exact thing he knew was weird for
him to do with Ethan Klein and the Hasan thing that makes him
look like a manipulative piece of [__] Right? Where
he's trying to use these friendships to pry these people apart.
demons towards these people towards some of the only good faith
libs left on the [__] chat who are nice to you. And
I'm nice to them. He doesn't know. You You as an Why do you think
Hutch came in here by the way? And despite the fact that Hutch
is getting buried, Hutch came in here and defended Pisco. Hutch
came in here and said actually Pisco is like right and this was
my opinion. Anyway, I'm
Why do you think Hutch did that? might be, but you as a streamer
are not. You're a terrorist. I'm a terrorist because I debate.
You bring Is that what I just said? I'm on one of the ground
of a [__] terrorist. I'm a terrorist. Terrorist should
be [__] How am I a terrorist? When I say that, what
do you think I mean? Do you think that I mean because You have
no clue whatsoever. What do you mean What do you mean I'm a terrorist?
If you have no clue whatsoever What What do you mean I'm a terrorist?
You should find somebody else to do the moderation or just say
you don't care about What do you mean I'm a terrorist? That's
kind of wild accusation. making fun of his dead sister or something
else. You say oh, I don't moderate my
So so you know you [__] up because that's an example
where immediately you
That wasn't in my chat. That wasn't in That wasn't in my chat.
That wasn't in my chat. That wasn't in my chat. That wasn't in
my chat.
It wasn't in my chat. I don't know. Like
And the people you draw of course are all [__] angels,
right? All the people you draw.
>> No no I mean no I don't have any specific concrete No
it wasn't. I mean you're you're describing that in your mind
I don't know it's very conspiratorial to think that like I'm
sitting in these chats to try to [__] you over or
something.
You're trying to force Pisq to take a
You're trying to force him to take a You you are trying what
you're trying to do right now is specifically to exert control
and to pressure for so that I comment on your case. I don't know
why you do that.
Do you think By the way do you think you could make up my opinion
aligning with Pisq's in this way? Do you think we could actually
like coordinate like this or do you think it's just that we're
both used to the manipulations coming from this person? We're
both seeing through the matrix and we're both seeing the same
thing. It's just reality, bro. It's just reality. Yes, we can
both see reality and call it out at the same time. Very simple.
See now you know what you're doing.
Okay. By the I'm not commenting on your case specifically. Is
it my intention that you are That is a great point, Aaron. Yes,
that Destiny wouldn't when Like it said if we're friends, you
don't think I'm an anti-Semite, right? And Destiny goes, "Well,
I don't know I don't know, man. I don't know. Maybe you are.
Maybe Maybe I don't even know, dude. I don't even know. Bro,
you did that to him when he was your podcast host. He was the
guy who was your He was your producer, sorry. Your podcast producer.
Well, I don't know. Maybe you are anti-Semitic, actually. children,
the answer is no to that question. But the answer The answer
is no to that question. The answer is no to that question. But
But But Steven, I'm not trying to get close I would rather this
never come up. I don't know why it's important for you to for
everyone who you interact with, or I guess we formerly interact
with, to get like statements on the record for that. I mean,
does that really make you feel better? I'm not trying to get
statements on the record. It's the people in your community are
the ones that run around and try to get statements on the record
from every single person about stuff related to me or other people
or You can rest assured that I'm not trying to comment on your
case for I know that you are not. That's what the conversation
is about. I'm not talking about what you say. I'm talking about
the behavior that running your chat. Okay, well, um to be honest,
I think that I don't care about it. I think you should have just
said that. You should say, I don't care if my chat is saying
crazy onion [__] about video. I just wonder when
Destiny's calling for like Pisco to be kicked off of the show,
Destiny's community is attacking Pisco constantly, they brigaded
Pisco's stream and community multiple times.
What do we What do we have to say if we applied this lens, okay,
if we applied this precise lens to the situation that Destiny's
doing, where you if you're a friend with somebody, you wouldn't
allow this to happen? What do we say about
Hutch and IRI in that case?
What do we What do we say about Hutch and IRI in that case? It
seem It seems like when they go on Destiny's stream and talk
to him all the time, so he pulls just one of his stream and talk
to him, although I think it was to disagree or something. I'm
just saying that like we wouldn't We don't apply this lens evenly,
right? This lens is not being applied evenly at all. I By the
way, I'm not making that criticism. I'm just saying the standard
Destiny's proposing is really You should have just said that
instead of doing this one
No, no, stop. What I think is is your unwillingness to ascribe
what you think ought to happen in these moderation channels.
Cuz I think you know it's something approaching um Protect Destiny
rule, it's okay to talk [__] about Hasan rule. It's
okay to talk [__] about people. I don't care what
anybody Hold on. Hold on. Do you think that I would care if you
or chat talked to [__] about me? Yes.
In what way? In any way that's critical of your positions, any
way that's Yes. >> don't think that I see You don't think
I see a difference at all between what I >> Yeah, no, I
think you see a difference there for sure. But I think you >> ever
been in the entire history of you knowing me, me going to anybody
in my orbit, anybody other than other streamers saying, "Hey,
these people are being mean to me in your chat. Can you moderate
that?" Have you ever heard of me doing that before? I'm not sure
that You literally Hold on. Huh, there's no way. You've been
[__] moaning about how this guy's chat treats you
for months. You've made two massive deals out of it. And then
when he says, "What do you want me to do?" You go, "I don't know,
man. I don't think you should do I don't even know what I would
say here. I just a small bean. I don't know what you should do."
You are [__] moaning about it constantly. And then
you go, "Have I ever told you to ban somebody?" No, because you're
too much of an avoidant
to do anything about your feelings.
You're here. You're obviously upset by it. Okay?
Dude, it's so [__] stupid. It's so
Isn't it strange that that you have that strong impression of
me? You don't want to know where that comes from? Maybe the chat
influences you a little bit more than you than you think it does.
My my my my my my my my my my my my my my my my my my my my my
my my my my my my my my my my my my my my my my my my my my my
my my my my my my my my my my my my my my my my my my my my Is
that what I'm saying? Is that a good faith interpretation of
what I'm saying? I'm not saying that that's I I I specifically
said it's not what you're stating. I'm saying it's an entailment
of your view. And I think one of the reasons you're uncomfortable
with
Do you want to finish that I want you to ban people who are talking
[__] about >> Yeah, yes, you you want me to
be to ban people who are negatively mentioning your drama in
my chat. Just admit it. Okay, hold on. Wait, wait, wait. That
was a little bit closer, for sure, right? Now, you don't have
to have that position, which is which is fine. You can have that
position. But that Your main your main contributing idea of the
chatter that was evil in Pisco's
was Doobie. Where did Doobie lie with any of his donations? Where
did Doobie lie? You want me to moderate people that are commenting
about your personal life or bringing up your personal drama,
right? Correct. That's a more accurate statement than me saying
than you saying that you want me to ban all criticism of you,
right? One of those is is way more specific than the other. Well,
no, no, I I think what I was saying with respect to would you
be upset if people are criticizing Destiny in your chat? And
the answer to that is [__] yes. I think that you
would be. No, no, I don't think I ever have. If you ever watch
me complaining about anything ever, I'm sure in your mind you
can think a lot of Destiny's probably complaining that people
are constantly bringing up personal stuff, baseless accusations,
lawsuit related accusations, my son, whatever else. How many
times have I been like, "Oh god, this guy in Peace Keeper's chat
says that I'm um I don't even know. Says that my opinion on whatever
I I can't even think of an example because nobody in your community
even Bro, we could just go look at the uh the Discord logs, all
the Discord logs he pulls up when it's just people spamming cat
pictures that when it's just people like talking normally, having
a totally normal conversation. He's trying to like manufacture
the idea that all these people are insane.
Right? Like we know that he gets upset just by people talking
[__] We know that. We've seen the evidence for it.
>> If they called you a If they called you a genocide supporter,
you wouldn't be upset if my chat was constantly calling you genocide
supporter, you support um Israeli war crimes, that you said that
um Israeli soldiers should do like you wouldn't have a problem
with that? I think I'd be annoyed, but but it's way different
than like No, I agree with you different. I agree with you different.
But one is it's okay. I can be annoyed at your chat. It's okay
to be annoyed at people's chats. Hutch's chat says stuff that
annoys me sometimes, okay? But there's like it's a different
level, right? If I went into Hutch's stream and all of Hutch's
chat is like, "Oh, not Destiny, he's an idiot. This guy's a That'd
be a lot different than me going into Hutch's chat and all of
them saying like, "Oh, this guy wants to rape children, right?"
One of these is like annoying. There's like, "Okay, Jesus Christ."
I agree. I agree they're different. And we Excuse me, sorry.
But um would understand them differently, 100%. I totally agree
with that. But just to be clear, the reason why I'm trying to
push for like different prescriptions is so that we can address
what you feel the issue is. And I don't think that you feel the
issue is bare accusations or mere accusations of misconduct.
I don't think that you think that that is a generally a problem.
I think it's a problem specifically perhaps with my co-host and
with you. >> Well, no, I'm saying my my my issue First
of all, this wasn't about your treatment towards me. My my issue
was that it seems like you conduct yourself in such a manner
that you become a lightning rod. He totally has to make this
about how Hutch is treated because he has seen how much of a
he looks like when he comes in just about his own stuff, right?
And even his his own chatters when they come about that stuff.
So, he needs to make this about Hutch's chat or about the the
treatment of Hutch cuz he doesn't want to make it about himself.
He knows he looks like a Maybe if he makes it about Hutch, he
can make it seem like it's like actually less biased. >> for
a whole bunch of anti-lib people that make a bunch of deranged
and bordering on personal comments or past that personal comments
towards people that are libs that come to your show. How many
people are calling Hutch a by the way? Kind of weird how the
Did anyone call Hutch a No, that's just a very strange thing
for me. >> Don't do that even as a joke, by the >> into
Hutch's chat and everybody saying like, "Oh, I bet I bet Pisco
is leaving cuz of some girl." I think that Pisco is Um uh he's
I don't even I don't even know cuz it's hard for me to imagine
these types of attacks against you cuz you don't make them. They
weren't anywhere near the the types of attacks that um that your
community is making towards other people. They accuse me of bad
faith constantly, and you do, too. Come on, that's a totally
different type of thing. Bad faith. I mean I would I would Oh,
I got to catch up, man. I'm going to do the adrenochrome injections.
If I knew that the worst attacks I'm getting Destiny's bad faith.
Dude, to be fair, I got that one. Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait,
wait, when they were making accusations of Hutch and like family
member, we acted quickly to resolve it. I instantly we figured
out where it was. I think it was maybe even during the conversation
with Honor Box. We stopped the on-screen chat, and we went to
address it. I I Yeah, you're not but you're not understanding
the question is >> Oh, listen, help me. Why are they there?
Does it Does it seem Yeah, and I know you don't want to answer
that one because it requires actual introspection and stuff.
He literally He literally answered the question like perfectly
accurately. >> Discord, they like Discord. >> No,
I didn't say that. I don't know if you're listening to me half
the time when I'm talking. >> I am. You I think you gave
three reasons. You said, one is because I am I don't ban people
who I disagree with in my chat. Um the second one is that I give
takes sometimes that uh I think are contrary to your takes. And
then you give the H3 Bos example, and then the third one was
that lefties might be drawn to your chat for Nice, yeah, no,
you did. I'm sorry, yeah, you did. You didn't listen. Okay, yep.
But the But the issue is not uh uh The issue is just I don't
I don't understand. Maybe you just don't care, I guess. I That
whole thing was true, by the way. That whole thing was true.
About All of these people watch Pisco. When Pisco By the way,
I've seen Pisco's chat when it's just him doing boring court
document Okay? I see Missy Elliott
I see a whole bunch of people there that I know. Destin Suggs,
I see you there. When Pisco's reading boring court documents.
I know Rhinox is there. I know a bunch of people from my community
watch Pisco do the most boring Okay? Cuz I'm watching sometimes
and I see them chat.
>> I think if Pisco is doing boring stuff and I'm live
I do get those chat
Yeah, I guess that's just a crazy >> was drinking it. That's
just a crazy thing to see I guess. Cuz I know that it would I
think it would bother you if you saw his chat making that level
of comments that level of commentary about you Genocide defender
and stuff? Genocide defender, um, Israel shill, that kind of
stuff. Maybe, but it's hard to I don't even know what the equivalent
of that is cuz there's not much of a snark right or whatever.
I don't even know what that would even look like. Cuz it's kind
of the left and that type of community that does that, um
But I I I've I've I've I've never asked I I've I've never I'm
saying I'm saying if I do drama and Pisco is just doing like
court document reading, I do get those chat logs. >> I'm
going to be honest, there's some critiques that you have made
of me that have bothered me. There are critiques that people
in your community that have made that have bothered me. I've
never once asked you to be like, hey, moderate >> What do
you mean bothered me? What do you mean bothered me? You know,
like comments that Hey, what was the Jimberly donation? Oh, hold
on. What was the Jimberly donation? I missed the Jimberly donation.
Something about Carolyn Kwan. Destiny tried to blow up Will Neff's
marriage with Carolyn Kwan for literally no reason other than
Ludwig told an embarrassing story about cheese balls. I don't
want to hear about personal attacks from him.
Also, yeah, exactly. Thank you. >> That made me rub the
wrong way. That made me that feel bad. Like calling it bad faith?
Like saying that I'm only having this opinion for the purpose
of ingratiating myself with an audience to try to suck up to
Hasan that I'm not these aren't my real opinions. I don't actually
have those opinions. >> This is live, yes. These are all
imputing my character. I feel like these are not comment I don't
know if these are common comments. I'm like I think most of us
are just really confused. Then some people are like, I'm a Pisco
hater from day one or something. I think most people are are
really confused. I don't know. I don't know. I don't know. I
don't know. You think I've changed? You think I've changed my
beliefs or like changed who I am? This is who I am. I've always
been combative and incredibly obvious what somebody on your show
or like what Hot will talk about. It'll it'll seem really obvious
like what's going on. And you are like debate Sometimes even
in front of a guest to where a guest gets out five words of a
of a question the Jose guy. I don't remember what the question
was. No.
That was well That was well into the
You grinded the [__] of him. And it's like holy [__]
What is the What is the purpose of this? >> And And what
you're saying is that's not what I'm known for doing.
No, I I I guess if you have one gear all the time. >> think
I have one gear all the time?
Totally why Destiny That's why they were friends. That's unironically
why they were friends in the first place, right? It's cuz Pisco
does go that hard on everybody. Pisco's learned a little bit
to chill a little bit, but it's like mostly on the surface. Like
if you actually tell Pisco he's wrong about something or that
you refuse to acknowledge something that's obviously true, he
doesn't have more than one gear. Sometimes around the edges he
could kind of be nicer. >> don't think so. But I think
you're capable of of not of not rolling in that gear. I think
that is super possible. I think 100% I think it's super possible.
Not Not when somebody's ignoring a clear logical contradiction.
It is not It's not that. >> say that. I roll with one gear
all the time. Maybe the answer is sometimes I get sort of um
prompted to be more combative in debate and sometimes I don't.
It's not like me deciding Machiavellianly to go after I'm not
I don't think I've ever said Machiavellian. You're You're describing
This is how people talk about me and I'm sure they talked about
me to you that way and I'm sure they're telling you that I talk
about you. It's very rare that I describe Machiavellianism regardless
of what you I saw your So So I'm just going to All cards on the
table, all right? I saw your review of my discussion with Hutch
and I'm like, you can't imagine how how bizarre it is for me
to like I get the message from Hutch, "Hey, let's let's talk
in the
Destiny's just lying to his face and Pisco's like, "Bro, I watched
you review the content. I literally know it. Why are you lying
to me right now? You're literally just lying to me." >> says,
"Let's battle." I think or something like that. And I'm like,
"I'm going to just let him ask me anything he
really assure him that I'm coming at this from the right perspective."
And your take was
Hutch, he's trying to with him. He This isn't even a real conversation.
It's not a real debate. Like, "Bro, you're describing lying to
me. Can you explain to me why at the end of that conversation
you asked Hutch, "You know that you're my boy, right?" And Hutch
couldn't even give you an absolute yes or no. Why do you think
he started on that? I think I hurt his feelings.
So then if that's your boy and you guys talk way more than than
me and you probably ever talked, and I'm confu- Why would it
be crazy that I'm confused on the outside of that if Hutch is
confused
I think that um
I think sometimes I undercount and underappreciate how much being
like pushed and pushed and pushed and pushed can have like an
effect on people. And not everyone is able to >> you're
pushing and pushing and all of your chat is the most vitriolic
that you by your own Dude, he he says you keep bringing up the
chat. You keep pushing and pushing and pushing. It's not about
the chat. Hutch is not looking at the chat. Hutch has already
said and explicitly pushed out any chat or outside interference.
Hutch came in and said Destiny was wrong on this, that Destiny
was making this up, right?
Hutch literally corrected Destiny on this in this conversation
and Destiny is still trying to push this.
>> Hutch says he doesn't really care about that. Hutch
has never Hutch has says he doesn't care about that. Hutch has
never communicated to me once that like he wants me to. I asked
him before, do you want me to ban over for you? He said no. >> told
you in this conversation that that wasn't the case. >> I
don't think anybody would ever say yes to that though. It doesn't
work that
But I don't think anybody would ever say absolutely could.
In private, somebody could totally say yes to that. I think Hutch
is the kind of person Hutch is very honest about his feelings.
Hutch talks about how going through NA like helped him get in
touch like be a more forgiving person and [__] He's
very like okay with discussing stuff. In private, I fully believe
he would say, "Yeah, this is getting to me. Could you chill a
little >> that he's um
was his feelings were hurt about that. >> totally wrong
and I might just be in a total imaginary world, okay? I'm not
actually. I won't hedge on that. I think that if Hutch was watching
a stream and you guys were having a debate and some guy in your
chat typed in some another unhinged personal attack about how
Hutch is simping for Diddy GG or is some is or some other weird
comment about Hutch and pro-genocide or something whatever the
[__] else. And you said be like, "Hey, He just constantly
slips in what his actual problem is, right? What his actual problem
is every time. He can't even He can't even keep it on track.
He just keeps putting back in what his actual problem is. It's
this thing where there are people who don't like me and I really
don't like it. We need to make it wrong to dislike me. >> not
cool or you like timed out that person or he saw that. I think
I think there'd be a little part of him where he'd be like, "Oh,
that's cool. Pisco cares about the image of me that's on his
stream and the way that his stream is perceiving me." Right.
You'd have to feel pretty You're categorizing the nature of the
comments You're cat- The nature of the comments that you're categorizing
as like beyond the pale are ones that relate I guess to Israel
or the genocide, and those that relate to like you. What other
clutch of criticisms, or what kinds of criticisms, that's what
I'm trying to like get a rule. Like what's what's the rule that
you think is a good rule by which to you know, sort of sort out
the harsh and biting and vicious and even unreasonable critique
or from beyond the pale, inappropriate, not even worth It's not
It's not going to be like a hard like you can't I I don't know
if you can make a rule like that. Like personal attack rule?
I mean, maybe. But like if I had to bootstrap like 50 rules to
chat saying like, "No racial slurs, no race realism, no race
essentialism, no What if I If every day you had to add a new
rule like that?" I think people would be like, "What the [__]
Why do we have 62 different rules related to how we can talk
about racial essential ideas?" Or racial essential I think they'd
be like, "Okay, this seems like a chat that is drawing these
types of people for whatever reason they really want to have
this conversation in here." And so the idea like you need to
make a new rule or ban the people doing it. Like if there's a
I don't like to be ad hoc. I don't like to be ad hoc. Maybe I
We could just go search straight rate in the DGG logs. How many
times is Pisco accused of How many times was Pisco accused of
simping for me just for streaming with me? I mean, we could check
out the logs. I'm sure there'd be a lot. >> I like to have
things be clear and up front about what the conduct is. And so
anything less than It's not about being ad hoc. I mean, like
if Like if you had to give it a shot here. So, one thing I noticed
when I talk about conservatives is is when whenever they want
to talk about anything, they always bring up trans people. Okay?
And I started joking about the girl [__] These guys
are obsessed with girl [__] If some point in time
>> What? Sorry, I'm missing this. I don't know. Sure. Anytime
conservatives would bring up trans people, they'd always say
they they're Anytime any political issue comes up, conservatives
talk about trans people. Always, every single time. Okay? So,
I started saying, "Okay, it's time for girl cock." We're talking
about girl [__] Eventually I got a debate in my chat
that was girl [__] girl [__] And I It
was funny, it's a good meme, but I noticed that maybe a month
into this, every single time anything related to trans people
came up on stream, anytime it came up, people started saying
girl [__] I'm like, "Okay, well, hold on. This is
kind of weird now. I don't think that it's a ad hoc rule to say,
'Okay, guys, we're not doing this.'" I think that if I see my
community portraying an image that I don't feel like accurately
reflects what I feel or what I think, I probably want to curb
down on that behavior depending on how extreme the behavior is
about things that I believe strongly in. So, if all my chat said
that they really like the movie Titanic and it was the best movie
ever, that's not anything I would care that much about. But,
if they're putting values or things out in the world that I severely
disagree with, like making extreme personal attacks against friends,
or having extremely divergent offensive political views, I would
probably do something to guide the community. But, it wouldn't
be a matter of like I'm just banning the word, all right? >> Well, you
just you just you just mentioned some things there that I think
could be made into rules. Like, for one, on the um the trans
issue, like anything related to intrinsic characteristics, those
kinds of attacks are unacceptable. Extreme personal attacks are
unacceptable. Extreme attacks that as against people's uh characters
who are friendly with the show, I don't even know I don't think
I have those rules in my chat. They might be, I don't think so.
But, but I think if somebody were to come on my stream and say
something like, "Oh, this guy's a back peddler." I don't think
I would need a rule against that. I think everybody in chat would
look at that person and type something like, "Feels weird, man."
And then they probably get banned or something. Or you probably
just leave. >> Yeah, when I say rule, I don't I don't I
don't mean like necessarily though I prefer He's trying to He's
trying not to come up with a rule because he's trying to get
people to enforce based on like protecting him. Like, he doesn't
want to say the rule. The rule makes him look like a [__]
So, he's just trying to bully Pisco and make him feel bad until
Pisco will do the thing that's good for
Over and over and over again. That's why he doesn't want to do
a rule. He knows the rule that he wants is not going to It's
either going to be way It's going to be something way outside
of what he would ever force himself, or it's not going to be
enough to protect him. So, he is going to continually emotionally
blackmail Pisco until Pisco is willing to to capitulate. And
I think Pisco might be the one guy who's capable of standing
up to this. >> So, there's so people know how I operate
on this cuz in my opinion, everyone should get a shot. Like,
I think everyone should get a chance to be in compliance. And
so, the rule is more just like a set of guiding criteria that
I can tell my mods cuz oftentimes I am just like listening to
the conversation, but also that I hold myself to following. And
so, it may be I don't think it's unreasonable for me to be like,
"Give me the rule." Or what do you think the a good rule would
be? Maybe it's something like that extreme personal attacks,
um or attacks, you know, repeated attacks against stream guests
or something like that. But, I don't think it's too much to ask
for. >> ban I would never ban somebody calling somebody
like bad faith. I don't think I would ever ban that. But, if
I had a friend that was coming to my stream, and every single
time he came in, every single person would be like, "Oh, bad
faith, bad faith, bad faith." I'd be like, "Well, [__]
What's happening right now that my whole community's interpreting
things like this?" I don't think I would ban the behavior. I
think I would either have a discussion about it, or I would do
something to try to guide them in a different direction. But,
remember earlier you said that after your four-hour conversation,
you felt like your community had an even worse opinion of Hot
takes afterwards. You had a four-hour talk about one hypothetical
that you said you were not any closer to the answer. And all
that what? It's not accurate that. The entire conversation was
about that. The conversation was about like what I view my political
theory as. It ventured into like personal like Well, sure. Sorry.
I'm sorry. I'm sorry. I'm sorry. I'm sorry. I'm sorry. I'm sorry.
I'm sorry. I'm sorry. I'm sorry. I'm sorry. I'm sorry. Well,
no. But I don't think it's my fault that I'm I don't think it's
my fault that I don't have any on that. It has to do with But
do you think that Lonerbox is at fault when you guys were on
that show Lonerbox had to call out like anti-Lebanese racism
in your chat related to supporting Is he at fault? No, that's
How does that Wait. Wait. Wait. Wait. Wait. Wait. Wait. Wait.
I heard that the Maronite comment was not from Pisco's chat in
that conversation. Am I crazy? Was that from Pisco's chat or
was that from somebody else's chat? Cuz I think I got told that
was not that anti that calling Lonerbox's dad a Maronite or something.
Somebody told me that that wasn't from Pisco's chat. How does
that make you feel when somebody makes that call out? Do you
feel anything? Lonerbox? It makes me feel sad.
And I'm sad. That's it? I don't know what you want me to say.
It feels bad. It feels bad. Wait, dude. Come on. This This is
so silly. You're you're Now you're getting triggered over me
saying sad and bad. What what [__] magic words do
you I would bring on somebody on my stream and my chat started
spamming racial slurs. That would be humiliating for me. I would
feel disgusted. I'd be like, "Well, hold on. This is not my community
at its best. This doesn't reflect what I believe in. I don't
think it reflects what I hope not my community is supposed to
believe in." I understand the huge gender disparity for the 90/10
male female stuff, but that's one of the reasons we talk about
the [__] women so much cuz I think a lot of the ways
that they treat women on or off whatever it is not the best.
And that's it's it makes me feel bad. I don't like it. I don't
enjoy when my community talks about it. And the fact that I don't
know if I was on a show and somebody was like calling out what
are like insanely disgusting comments in my chat. I think I'd
be like, "Oh, [__] Like let me get the like that's
the kind of thing >> you're a woke victory lap cuz I said
bad and sad and you're like, "Wow, you should have elaborated
more and like gone on a [__] And that's how you Is
that If that's how you feel, I mean I it was it was your decision,
but I mean it seems like you said you don't care much about There's
the There's the Just see. It's just emotional signaling. Let
me talk Let me talk real quick. No. Never rule. I I feel Listen.
I'm willing to give you the benefit of the doubt because I'm
argumentative, too. And I'm just generally like optimistic about
people, but I have definitely told you a number of times that
your chat is pretty unhinged. So, when I hear you say like no
one said anything, I get confused by that. Cuz it's kind of like
a running meme on the on the podcast, right? Well, I didn't know
that you wanted me to get like rid of those people.
Well, I mean, I don't know if I said ban people, but I we've
definitely like it's been said multiple times. >> Why can't
Why can't any of these people just say I don't want I don't want
them talking [__] about me? All I'm talking about
is like that it upsets you such that you think that like
You can ask for this, by the way. You can ask for this. >> Action
should be taken. That's what I'm getting at. Yeah, like some
kind of moderation. Like if you think like it's ban worthy, then
that's that's up to you, but like some kind of moderation. So,
like people in my chat sometimes will if we're debating, they'll,
you know, accuse you of bad faith or or whatever, but if you
if you talk to my chat or if you ask them, they will all tell
you that I I almost always, like when I see it like really picking
up, I basically every single time will tell chat like, "Okay,
chill. You can have disagreements with this debate, but like
don't don't don't do like the crazy ad homs, which is a little
bit different than, you know, like I'm not actively like banning
>> Hold on. But the crazy ad homs are where Pisco said
he was banning, right? Like the um like the thing something about
Hutch's sister or something. >> you have to go pretty far
in my chat to get a ban. But I do make an effort to like if they're
friend of the stream, you know, don't don't like start accusing
this person of wanting to like murder babies or whatever. Um
I did have to take the chat off of my screen when we do the podcast
a lot of times cuz cuz I would get so distracted. Cuz like the
the things that people were saying about me in your chat was
like literally like, you know, sweeping for genocide and you
know, but like the the wildest straw man arguments I've ever
seen in my life. And so, that does get to be a little bit
you know, I just kind of I think I just kind of got to a place
where I dismissed it. I'm like, "Okay, I guess he's just idiosyncratic
like that. Maybe he's like a maximalist free speech kind of person,
This is Pisco just needs to say if you could bring me the chat
messages, you go to my mod team with the chat messages that you
think are unhinged or whatever, like totally crazy. And if it's
like, you know, talking about your family, talking about um I
don't know >> People from my community know that. Now,
if if it bothers you, I can we can definitely get rid of it in
the context of our podcast. 100% yeah. I didn't know that it
bothered you. Well, I mean, listen. We have said stuff before,
Pisco. No, but it's I didn't I didn't I I didn't know that it
bothered you such that you think you should take No, but why
would why would we bring it up if it didn't bother you? Well,
it could be that you're commenting on it because you think it's
crazy. I didn't know that you specifically wanted action. I mean,
that's just if you wanted me to clean up the chat in the context
of our podcast, I'm happy to do But why would I Why would I bring
it up?
I Yeah, so this is the the problem. This is the whole thing is
is Pisco's going to be the person who wants a rule, wants people
to be clear with what they want. And this is how this is always
going to >> I have no idea. Like you're bringing it up
to express your dissatisfaction with it. I don't take that to
be a view that you like want me to take particular
Why don't I just make it clear? You want me to ban people who
are doing stuff? So So you want me to ban people who do what?
Who are >> wants you to ban people who say what they want
to want to do
I You want me to want to I just so correct about all of this.
It's very >> Not ban people, but just like >> Take
action against who? It's not about that. Who do you want me to
Do you think it's embarrassing for Destiny to be the guy who's
like, "Pisco, I just want you to be nicer. Pisco, could you just
be nicer on Twitter? Pisco, could you just be nicer? Could you
like moderate nicer? Could you Could you make your chat be nicer?"
Do you think Do you think that Destiny feels any shame being
the guy who he embarrassed in debates for years on end? For years
on end.
It's crazy. >> me to take action against? I I don't know
how to say this without sounding like super um like virtue signaling,
but when I see people making like extreme personal attacks. And
And I don't always get everything. Like I don't always see So
So there could be things that that go through the cracks, but
my moderators know to to like crack down if it if it reaches
a certain kind of threshold. That's just So that's my instinct
cuz cuz like we're pod pals or whatever. And so my instinct is
to be like, "Chill. You guys You guys should chill." And so like
when I look at the Living and Learn chat And you know, like half
of the chat >> You know, I stopped it in You know, like
accusing Illustrative Joe, obviously that's true, but listen,
not substantive here, okay? It's not actually material to the
conversation. We can make the argument without having to invoke
that >> supporting genocide. Then I It did get to a point
where I was like, "I'm just not even going to look at the chat."
Uh cuz it was distracting. Like it was like really intense kind
of accusations. Well, listen, I didn't know that um you wanted
me to take that more more >> Pisco, why are you Pisco,
why are you saying that? >> I'm lying? You think I'm lying
to you? You think I'm I'm I'm telling the truth. I don't I I
don't know what to make of this, Pisco, if I tell just me saying
hey, how's the weather? It's not the same kind of like conversation.
It's like me that's obviously me. >> I'm sorry. I feel
like you're like the boyfriend girlfriend situation where it's
like, why don't you just say what you mean? Why don't you just
like this is what I feel like. I just like I maybe have like
a a more
but truly I didn't get the inclination that you you wanted me
to take any particular action. And even as I sit here like it
sounds like what you want me to do is have people calm down about
you which I do at times and and so I don't know I'm just like,
well, you want me to do it more
Or is it me even asking like insulting to you? Like the fact
that I'm asking it is is is like anathema to you. I mean, I'm
a bit incredulous right now cuz like About what?
It's I don't know. Like I can I can I can forgive
like being idiosyncratic in certain ways but if I I know that
it came up like multiple times. It wasn't just like once or twice.
It was it became like a running gag like a meme on the chat where
it was like that and then the joke was like we all know who's
you know chat that person came from. Often times those people
weren't in my chat but like even putting that aside like I took
that as a joke and as you guys like expressing I didn't take
that as you saying do something. And if that was what you were
trying to communicate, I did not have that communicated to me.
And I'm not lying about that. I think you're accusing me of of
lying.
Are you? No, I I I I don't know I truthfully I don't know how
to make sense of it cuz cuz
it's difficult for me to
put myself in your shoes and and have like it's fine if people
like if people are saying like all these bald or 40 40-year-old.
Like that stuff the superficial stuff that I could give a [__]
less. That like that doesn't bother me. But if I look at the
chat and it
um this guy like it's with the with the particular crowd that
I'm thinking of, they relentlessly lie. Like relentlessly lie.
And I think it's because a lot of them watch Hasan and he relentlessly
lies. Like he has accused me as recently as just like a week
and a half ago of being paid by Progressive Victory to do Israeli
propaganda. If I if I ask your chat right now like how many people
in your chat think that I was paid by PV to do Israeli propaganda?
It's It's It's definitely definitely not a representative sample
cuz the views have have been up for All they're all juiced up
because of the uh Yeah. Oh, I see. But But if it was like a regular
audience, I feel like it would be like a decent chunk of them
that believe that. I'm not That stuff I find That stuff I find
like pretty unsettling. It's It is an unsettling experience on
the internet to look at a chat and see like dozens of people
saying that this guy was paid to do Israeli propaganda.
I just wish that these people understood that like if you just
pull someone into talk, when people say these things, I just
pull them into talk and watch them fall apart.
Like that's the whole thing. Pull them into talk. Watch them
fall apart, man. >> I have no thought about that. Like
I see your chat sometimes being negative towards me. Um maybe
you're saying different kind or something. Um maybe I didn't
perceive that different kind. Uh with respect to the chats, I
understand that my status like very specifically antagonistic
at times towards things you're saying. But I I truly didn't know
that you wanted me to take additional No, no, no. Pisco, when
they say that you're like a terrible person, a terrible friend
who's like really psychotic and doesn't care about anybody, that's
true. So, they get to say that about you, but when somebody's
name is Destiny, sorry, Rose is 17, that's like if Rose was 17,
then Destiny's a And like that's really unconscionable to say.
Actually, and if No, but you don't you don't think that my chat
goes as hard as your chat, do you? That's not what you're saying,
right? I'm not saying that I'm not making an assessment there.
I'm saying that they're both highly negative. No, but you acknowledge
that By the way, I think that's what like DG Yiers think. I don't
think that. You acknowledge that you acknowledge that your chat
goes way beyond like what you see in my chat,
Admit you're a Hasan  J Star orbiter bro. Just admit it.
Get off your Get it off your chat.
Uh-huh. It's like a difference again, it's like a difference
between like a Pisco arguing in bad faith, which is like, you
know, that's like, you know, kind of a nasty accusation. But
like compare that to, you know, oh well, you know, Hutch got
paid to do genocide apologetics. Like that's Those These are
very different scales, you know, what I mean? I don't I don't
want both of them in my in my stream. But I agree that those
are like different things. It's like implying that you're getting
paid by the state of Israel or some [__] Um that's
different than implying to like bad faith accusations. Um maybe
it's different also to like the Griffin accusations in that a
Griffin or audience captured accusation, which you agree you
can find plenty of it in the Hutch comment section, correct?
That is like that your audience captured? Yeah. Yeah, um some
people say that. But you know what I do every time, bro? Every
single time I see that, I'm like, "Hang on, guys. I Like I will
I've said this probably two dozen times in my chat, some variation
of this. Like guys, I understand that there's a lot of commentary
about Pisco. I have not seen any evidence that he's like in the
tank for tankies or actively trying to like court Hasan's audience.
Like I push back very directly every time I see that. Okay, I
know that people take it like as a joke, this Hasan my boy thing.
I think that a lot of throat clears like that, unless they're
supported by actual action, um like lose a lot of their effect.
Um maybe I should be more sort of targeted when I do throat clears,
but the intent is to suggest that I think you're operating in
good faith. Um and that it's like not a personal thing, and that
I largely um I don't want them to get a wrong impression from
whatever I'm about to say. But that has sort of turned into Well,
I think See, here's the other thing that you could think there.
And I don't I don't know what Pisgo thought, but he could think
that oh, if if people are saying things that I don't agree with
about Hutch, I'm going to correct those more often. Right? I'm
not going to ban those people, but I'll correct them more often.
clear which is meant to like signal abuse or something or bullying
of you or some [__] So, so maybe um and here I'm
like I'm generally looking to see like what I didn't expect you
to um come on, uh to be honest, cuz I truly I truly didn't think
that you wanted me to do anything else, but I'd be willing to
workshop ideas with you about how you think I should approach
going forward. Maybe No, but No, but I was No, but I was hearing
you say that nobody brought it up to you in the past, but that's
not true. No, people have brought it up to you in the past. People
on the podcast have brought it up to you in the past. Do you
think that when I said that I was meaning that no one has brought
up my chat before? What do you think I meant by that? Yeah. Yeah.
I mean that's not I can just tell you that's not what I What
I meant by that was I don't know how to make this I mean you
said, "Well, no one no one has told me that it bothered So, I
mean I guess maybe literally that's true. I I don't know if I've
ever literally said like, "Hey, that bothers me." But You haven't.
Okay, but I mean if I'm again, if I'm if I'm
bringing it up in the way that I've done in the past, and it
wasn't even just me, but like
if I'm bringing it up in that way, like, "Bro, your chat is wild.
Some of the stuff they're saying about me is wild."
You know, like
what what do you think I'm saying by that? You think I'm just
like marveling at it like a like a waterfall or
I think that you're signaling disagreement with it. I think that
you're you know, I don't think that you're suggesting particular
course of conduct. Maybe that's stupid of me to to interpret
it that way, but like I took the running gag of it to be like,
"This is all something we accept." If like I'm going to be honest
with you, in organizations, I I think or in like sort of setups
with different
uh people, I think that communication, maybe we should have like
meetings and [__] or something or like a a monthly
meeting because um I I think that that this is an opportunity
for us to
to potentially like be on the same page
cuz I I'm telling you I just had no impression that you wanted
me to to I don't By the way, I think the normal person thing
to do here is when somebody says, "Hey, I have a problem with
this or this is like really shitty that this is happening." They're
asking you for Right? I think we can always infer they're asking
you for help.
Pisco's I think Pisco's legitimately to to read it that way.
I don't think it's like a thing. I just think it's really funny
that I can tell that he's too to to see this and other people
aren't. He does want to hold a retro. Yes, he does. Monthly retro's.
Yes.
Some of those are important, okay?
But now now listen, we you have this conversation for long enough
where people are just constantly emotionally signaling and this
person's good faith, right? Pisco's being good faith the whole
conversation with people who just want to emotionally signal
and either get their way or make them look bad. Eventually, you're
going to lose. If you're operating in good faith and these people
just want to make you look bad, they just want to get their way,
you are going to look bad eventually. But Pisco's got to learn
that, you know, sometimes the only way you learn that the stove
is hot is you put your hand on the stove, okay? Sometimes that's
how you got to learn >> act differently with respect to
my job.
You can say that's your incredulous about that. It's just like
I I didn't think that even in the last thing that you just said
with with Steven here, you were like, "It doesn't bother me."
Like so, I don't know. I I really didn't know that. our our debates
our debates like whatever back and forth >> that you said
the reply people don't bother you. That's what I So, that's what
you said previously. And so, I do And when you said that, I was
like, "Oh, that makes sense." To be clear, I meant like the the
personal insults. Like that that stuff after 17 years of being
on the internet, it's like whatever. I don't really care. Like
the the the really kind of super this this super the really kind
of superficial kind. But like for example, um when we got If
If personal insults
Okay. added into the segregationist discourse. It was like If
basically been every week since that
That if I if I open chat and look at it There's
going to be like people in the chat that are saying like oh this
is the guy that wants segregationists to come back into the Democratic
Party. Like like that is That's beyond like a superficial that's
beyond like a superficial you know old bald whatever thing. That's
like blatantly misinterpreting.
Like even I'm looking at your chat right now. I I don't have
You know what I mean like YouTube one I I didn't activate the
um Because we undid it I I can't see the YouTube one I can only
see the kick. I should have probably shut No but but but like
that some of the some of the chat that I look at right now in
in that's active right now is like the same stuff that shows
up in the podcast where it's like this is the same guy that actively
wants to court segregationists.
And it's like I don't know I'm trying to ascertain what things
bother you Hutch. I'm I'm I I really am just trying to know what
bothers you that that I I know. to you though. Oh okay. But I'm
trying to I'm trying to explain it to you though right? Like
If you call me bald I don't give a [__] If you say
you know I'm older weird looking I don't give a [__]
If you say that I actively want to court segregationists into
the Democratic Party like that is so beyond above us any kind
of superficial insult that I'm talking about. And I don't know
if it's because these people are just fully
There's some internet communities that are kind of centered around
like a cult of personality or like there's anti
Yeah I I think
Unfortunately Missy what you're not understanding is almost certainly
has been shown like comments. And so they just jump to these
like wild conclusions. I don't know if they actually believe
these things or if they're just trying to like discredit me by
repeating these insane accusations. But it's like that stuff
that I think that takes it to like a new kind of Like it's beyond.
I'm bothered when people in your chat say that I'm grifting for
tankies and I would like you to delete all those comments. But
Pesco I I'll delete all the I'll delete all the comments about
about that you're referencing. No but Pesco every time I see
those kinds of comments, every single time. I say to my chat,
guys, I do not think he's courting tankies. Like ask any regular
in my chat. Okay, when I see those comments I'll see I I I have
said before that I think it's a mischaracterization of your view
that you want to invite Epstein Epstein people or segregationists
into the party. But when I see it, I will go out and say that
that's not true. Cuz I don't believe it and I I agree with that.
I will make that commitment to you. Okay, that would be great.
That would be great. No, but this is what I think is great about
reaching out because I have I truly I'm going to be honest like
I did not know that it that those kinds of comments bother you.
And um it seems like they more relate to misinterpreting your
arguments and sort of bad faith interpretations that seem malicious.
That's the kind of stuff that bothers you, right? It's It's It's
the
It's the wild like strong
I'm in basically. Wild wild wild accusations. Hutch literally
thinks that Epstein would be like a good president or Hutch literally
wants to like actively court segregationists into the party.
Um that stuff is Do not joke about that. Do not joke about that.
is a part of like a Big Bungey is bad. We disavow Big Bungey
here officially, guys. Get Big Bungey out of here. >> larger
coordinated effort by the people that I spar with. Like you're
aware that these that these communities and these creators just
actively lie, right? Like you're you're aware of that, right?
Um which communities? Hassan communities? They lie, yeah. All
all that. I mean it like Hassan but like But it's so much bigger
than Hassan. It's like Mike is it? Like all of that like extended
universe. Like you're aware that they knowingly blatantly lie
like regularly, right? Where? Where?
>> No, no, that's not what I asked you though. But like
that those communities. The regularity of it isn't something
They're foundationally liars. Oh god. I don't watch enough of
these people's content to say in those terms. I know that they
lie a lot. Okay. It is a lot. It is a lot. And it's a deliberate
strategy. If they feel vulnerable in any kind of way, they don't
really like to engage in the substance of whatever critique is
going on at the time. And one of the ways that they avoid engaging
in the substance is to just try to discredit people by just blatantly
lying about them. So, accusing Kors people of being paid to do
genocide apologia the way that that whole crowd does with like
Brian and and Kors and all them. And or or accusing
people that did work with PV of of being paid to do Israeli propaganda,
which in the case of PV is particularly insane because one of
the last canvassing events that they did when I was still working
with them was for Jamaal Bowman.
So, that it's not it's not even just that they lie, it's that
they that is that they like blatantly
lie about the dumbest things. And they know they're doing it.
And the whole reason they do it is because they want to just
they they want to discredit you so they don't have to actually
engage in what you're This is like a endemic to that whole scene,
that whole like toxic sludge. Yeah. And so, when I see like some
of the stuff that I see in your chat sometimes where it's like
I feel like
probably a lot of overlap with those communities. It's because
it's they're saying the same things that show up in my mentions
when people like Mike and Hasan bring up like a tweet of mine
and like blatantly brigade and accuse me of of doing things
I obviously never did. Sorry, I'm moderating my community.
All right. No, I listen, I don't like those communities. I don't
know what you like I agree, I don't like those communities. What
do you want me to say?
Okay, yeah. I'm just explaining
it's it's it's the same it's the same rhetoric.
Like the the rhetoric that looks like that, you know, like if
if if if one of those creators pulls up a tweet of mine and like
just >> You guys don't know what's going on. It's pretty
funny. >> that said he, you know, uh like segregationist
Put live DGG chat on screen, it's so unhinged. I would, but I
don't like doxxing people and almost certainly they're going
to spam doxxes of people in that chat cuz that's what they do.
So, I would rather not do that, you know what I'm saying? I'd
rather not have like doxxes of people flash by on my screen.
>> Segregation should come back to the Democratic Party.
And then they pulled it like a tweet up on their screen and the
whole point is like they're
using their communities I don't do that and I don't like that
they do that, too. I don't know what you want me to say. No,
I know you don't. No, I know you don't do that. I'm I'm saying
it's the ones that mirrored that those tactics and that rhetoric.
That Okay. >> That I find The ones that mirror the tactics
and rhetoric of these communities that hate you.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. Like the blatant
bad faith interpretations of things that I say or like blatant
straw men. Yeah, that stuff is crazy to me.
Okay. Well, listen. I have to go. I have heard what you said,
Hutch. And frankly, I I hear you and I want to I'm open to
to trying to address it for the sake of
you know, making it more palatable.
Well, listen. I would have I would have
probably preferred to to to do this privately. The only reason
I wanted to >> I ask Can I ask why you didn't?
Well, because I In the first instance, it was because you guys
were having this really long conversation about why I said the
things that I said and it and it was getting frustrating. Like
somebody messaged me to to tell me that you guys were talking.
By the way, Pisko, not being a whiny [__] I'm pretty
sure won't hold this against Hutch. Now, he might ask why here,
but I'm guessing he'll show up to live and learn next week and
still be friends with Hutch. >> And then the second time
was because I kept hearing you say that no one had um told you
that the chat stuff like had bothered them. Or no one had like
brought it up to you before. I don't know exactly what you said.
I mean, I I I I didn't get the impression that you guys wanted
me to take particular action or that you guys were being bothered
by by chatters, except except that we've had a couple instances
where it's been like horrible and then we've addressed them.
Um
but uh yeah, I guess I don't know why
did you feel that it would be best to have this conversation
in public?
Well, I mean, you were having the conversation in public, right?
Well, I was having the conversation in public about um whether
or not I was good faith in interpreting you know, your statements,
whether or not I felt that my moderation was was good based on
my view of what um y'all were sort of feeling about the chats.
And I didn't know that you wanted me to take particular action.
Um I'm not saying that it's like totally
to be public, but um I am just just wondering the thought process
there.
Well, you You were you were having a conversation publicly and
I felt like some of the things that you were saying were not
representative of Well, I will say so.
I I think this way. Not a lot of people think this way.
Actually, everybody thinks this way. They just don't think this
way when they're upset about the thing happening. So, to me I
would know if if this was my friend, I wouldn't go litigate this
in public right now because of how it would be used against my
friend. But Hutch does feel like um like right now he can get
his way, this would be a good time for him to raise his concern.
Right? Turns out Hutch is using his leverage at the prime point
in time when Pisco is most vulnerable. Kind of like a leftist
almost not wanting to endorse Kamala because the threat of Trump
is so large. A little bit.
Everybody's like this a little bit,
I I don't I listen, I don't have a ton of judgment of it. I I
get it. I think you can't be that mad with people bringing up
their issues with you in public. >> You're feeling my experience.
My experience. Got it. Okay, well, listen, I'm totally willing
to to address the concerns. Let's let's let's chat more about
them. And um and yeah, I'm I'm not unreal I'm just I'm not going
to hold it against Hutch. I feel like it's for Pisco because
it's going to be used to like narrative weave all over Twitter,
but it like it's his right to do it. >> man, like I don't
want you to feel horrible about how the chat is doing. I don't
want to
to get people like to or encourage or
stay silent when there are people coming after you who >> Yeah.
Like listen, just listen, we should go back and cover that. We
should actually go back and cover that um that anything else
stream with Dan. We should go listen to that again and how they
treat Lycan. It's goofy. I would never want to do that.
All right. Do you feel like Do you feel like I want to encourage
people to hurt you and I too? No, I don't I don't think that
about you. No, I don't I In fact, I told you the last time we
spoke. I I
the way that I The best way to resolve this is just basically
like letting Pisco know that you're a little you're a little
impaired emotionally. You're a little impaired, okay, when it
comes to
You're a little impaired. Sometimes you might Do Do you have
like a touchstone? Do you have like an empathy touchstone who
could kind of tell you how to act with certain other people sometimes?
Cuz it might be important to have like an empathy touchstone.
Uh and that's not Destiny cuz Destiny's not he's totally The
way that I rationalize in my head is is honestly with you Pisco
I just I just chalk it up to to you being a bit idiosyncratic
in this kind of way. That's how I've always been, man. I mean,
ask people back in the day from the early days of uh of my Discord
and my chat. I'm hands-off. I'm very hands-off. I always have
been. It's not a a directed or particular thing. I I I promise
you that, but um I obviously you know, care about um how it's
affecting the Live and Learn Cinematic Universe. And so, I have
no problem, you know, engaging with you two to talk about potential
changes and how I can address going forward so that you feel
heard, you feel seen, and that people feel like they know where
I stand. I feel like
this was a productive conversation. Yeah. What I'm hearing from
you is No, I'm I'm joking. I'm doing therapy speak. Um yeah,
no. All right, well, listen. Enjoy the rest of your weekend.
Hey, appreciate you. >> Wow, what a stream. Just a quick
question. Oh, no, you're I enjoyed that thoroughly. You guys
are like chilling, huh? We have like a big storm coming.
I just want to make It's been pretty cold. It's been pretty cold
by Los Angeles standards, um but not not freezing or anything.
Well, listen, brother. I hope you're Hope you have a wonderful
Sunday. And um we'll talk soon, bro.
You too. Take it easy. All right. Peace
Yo. Yo. YouTube chat, super sorry. Super super sorry for um not
having you on screen. I just uh I think because I started a new
one, I had to like >> Another Jimble Lee don't know. Oh,
[__] >> weird thing. It's unlike Twitch and
Kick. So, hold on. I'm going to read both of these Jimble Lee
donos cuz they're both good. Sitting here thinking about Destiny
standing 10 toes down and blowing up his podcast for saying the
slurs in private and ta- talking all the gu- taking all the guff
necessary to defend it and wondering where that guy
Yeah, that's it's not the same guy
Um Destiny tried to blow up Will Neff's marriage with Carol.
Oh, we saw this already. Wait, did I miss? Ah, whatever.
there's like a persistent one. So, sorry about that. I was locked
in. Yeah, having snow. Uh I did clock it perfectly, Matt. I did
clock it perfectly. I will say
I was banned from the Pisco Discord cuz cuz Destiny wanted to
post, you know, me basically saying like I called this. I called
this, okay? And I I just quoted him and I was like, "Yeah, I
did call it. You did exactly what I said you were going to do."
And that was enough to get me banned. I think I technically Technically,
by commenting on Pisco's stream in Pisco's Discord, I was violating
a rule of Pisco's Discord. So, technically, I was violating the
rules of his Discord. Not upset about getting banned. That's
what happens if you violate the rules. I
I personally am just sitting here like
I'm just trying to be protective of this guy's community cuz
I've watched what Destiny has done to my community by threatening
to dox all these people and it started with the same [__]
about like, "Oh, you have to moderate like these people who dislike
me." Look at how unhinged these comments are, right? It started
it started
with what is happening to Pisco right now and it eventually progresses
to fully doxing a bunch of people. So, I'm sitting here and just
going, "Oh, this is what he's going to do. This is how he's going
to try to attack you. This is how he's going to emotionally signal."
And if he had a complaint, if he had a real complaint, he could
apply. He would give you a prescription.
Destiny totally failed to give any prescription, exactly as I
said, and he only emotionally signaled and tried to post screenshots
from like logs of Pisco's Twitch chat or something to show that
Pisco's a mean a big fat meanie. Pisco's just a big fat meanie.
Meanwhile, if Pisco wanted to go unhinged at all, he could easily
just show logs of DG Yiers doxing like multiple people, Destiny
doxing multiple people. All right, folks. I got to go to bed.
I'm actually We're trying to beat the uh
We're trying to beat the
the snow tomorrow, so. I love you guys very much. Stay cool.
If you're on the East Coast
Bye Pisco. Be safe. Wow, what a stream. What What a stream.
What a stream.